I know it's early in the year, but we're already talking about our summer family trip. And you know we like to Airbnb. I know this. Well, we like to have a kitchen and I like to be able to walk out in my robe in the morning and have a cup of tea and as you call it, Jenna, I like a long runway. Yes. Well, you know, Lee is working in Oklahoma right now and we're going to come out to visit him and he got us a really nice Airbnb to stay in as a whole family. So that we could spread out, and everybody could sleep well. And then you feel like you're at home,
我知道现在才年初，但我们已经在讨论暑假的家庭旅行了。你知道我们喜欢住Airbnb。我知道。嗯，我们喜欢有厨房，我喜欢早上穿着睡袍走出来喝杯茶，正如你所说的，珍娜，我喜欢长长的跑道。是的。嗯，你知道，李现在在俄克拉荷马工作，我们要去看他，他给我们找了一个非常好的Airbnb，全家人住在一起。这样我们就可以分散开来，每个人都能睡个好觉。然后你会觉得就像在家里一样，
even though you're in a different city. Lady, I don't wanna sleep in the same room as my whole family. That's why I can't do hotels great anymore. Yeah, cause you all bunk up, and share a bathroom. Yeah, I like the space. I like a refrigerator, a real refrigerator. I like to have snacks, as you know. I do know this. Yes, correct. I don't want to call room service. I want them right there. That's right. Yeah. Everyone, we're ladies who Airbnb, I guess, for your next adventure, for your next
即使你在一个不同的城市。天哪，我不想和我的全家人睡在同一个房间里。这就是为什么我再也受不了酒店了。是的，因为你们都挤在一起，共用一个浴室。是的，我喜欢空间。我喜欢冰箱，一个真正的冰箱。你知道，我喜欢吃零食。我确实知道这一点。是的，没错。我不想叫客房服务。我想要它们就在那儿。没错。是的。各位，我想我们是爱住Airbnb的女士，为了你的下一次冒险，为了你的下一次
vacation, maybe consider Airbnb. With the Fizz loyalty program, you get rewarded just for having a mobile plan. You know, for texting and stuff. And if you're not getting rewards like extra data and dollars off with your mobile plan, you're not with Fizz. Switch today. Conditions apply. Details at fizz.ca. Welcome to Second Drink of the Entry. This is one of Jenna's favorite episodes. It really is. And lady, I have some new fun tidbits to share. I'm going to start with a cold open that was in the shooting draft that we didn't discuss.
假期，也许可以考虑Airbnb。有了Fizz忠诚度计划，你只需拥有一个移动套餐就能获得奖励。你知道，发短信之类的。如果你没有通过移动套餐获得额外数据和折扣等奖励，那你用的就不是Fizz。今天就切换吧。条件适用。详情请访问fizz.ca。欢迎来到《Second Drink of the Entry》。这是珍娜最喜欢的剧集之一。确实是。而且，女士，我有一些新的有趣花絮要分享。我先从剧本中有一个我们没有讨论过的冷开场开始。
Oh. So in our original breakdown, we talked about how there were no Jim and Pam flirty moments in this entire episode. But guess what? There was a flirty cold open and it's why Jim and Pam are in moments in this entire episode. But guess what? There was a flirty cold open, and it's why Jim and Pam are in such a good mood when Michael calls about his foot. Yes!
哦。所以在我们最初的细分中，我们谈到了这一整集中没有吉姆和帕姆调情的时刻。但你猜怎么着？有一个调情的冷开场，这就是为什么吉姆和帕姆在这一整集中……但你猜怎么着？有一个调情的冷开场，这就是为什么吉姆和帕姆在这一整集中……心情这么好，当迈克尔打电话说他的脚受伤时。是的！
Right? They're both at front reception. This is how it read in the shooting draft. Interior office reception area. Pam sits at her desk, Jim's there too. They are playing happy face, sad face. Pam laughs at Jim's sad face and she loses. Jim says, there it is, three to one. You are terrible at this. And Pam goes, okay, okay, okay, let's try again. And then Pam psychs herself up, pinches her cheeks so she won't
对吧？他们都在前台。剧本里是这样写的。室内办公室接待区。帕姆坐在她的办公桌前，吉姆也在那里。他们在玩“笑脸，哭脸”。帕姆对吉姆的哭脸大笑，她输了。吉姆说，就是这样，三比一。你在这方面太差劲了。帕姆说，好吧，好吧，好吧，我们再试一次。然后帕姆给自己打气，捏了捏自己的脸颊，这样她就不会
smile. She does a killer happy face and then an equally ridiculous sad face. Jim tries to remain straight face then laughs. Pam triumphantly says, three, two, and then the phone rings. Oh my goodness. I don't even remember shooting that. That's what's so wild about that. Well, you know what? It's so interesting because we were talking about how after booze cruise and that big 27 seconds of silence,
笑了。她做了一个超赞的笑脸，然后是一个同样荒谬的哭脸。吉姆试图保持面无表情，然后笑了。帕姆得意地说，三，二，然后电话响了。天哪。我甚至不记得拍过那个镜头。这就是最疯狂的地方。嗯，你知道吗？这很有趣，因为我们之前在讨论《酒船》之后，那27秒的沉默，
where do they go from here? And then it just wasn't addressed at all. They don't hardly interact, but they did flirt. I wonder if that's why they took this out. To create that tension. Yeah, they didn't want to relieve the tension just yet. Well, when I was looking at our old comments for this episode, I saw such a fun catch from Edgetsagrammar. And here's what it says. Can we start a George Foreman grill tracker? It appears at least four times.
他们从那里去哪儿了？然后根本就没有解决。他们几乎没有互动，但他们确实调情了。我想知道这就是他们删掉它的原因吗？为了制造那种紧张感。是的，他们还不想缓解那种紧张感。嗯，当我查看我们这一集的旧评论时，我看到了Edgetsagrammar的一个非常有趣的发现。它是这样说的。我们可以开始一个乔治·福尔曼烤架追踪器吗？它至少出现了四次。
Ben Franklin, dinner party, dream team, and garage sale. And obviously, the injury. That's a lot. That's a lot of George Foreman grills. And you know what? In deleted scenes, we find out that Jim has a George Foreman grill too. Listen to this. I've had a Foreman grill for about six years. I've done about 85% of my cooking on it, but I've never burnt myself, probably because I don't use it as a pillow. Well, lady, I mean, I feel like everybody had a George Foreman grill. I had a George Foreman grill.
《本·富兰克林》、《晚宴》、《梦之队》和《车库大甩卖》。显然还有这次受伤。这太多了。这太多的乔治·福尔曼烤架了。你知道吗？在删除的场景中，我们发现吉姆也有一个乔治·福尔曼烤架。听着：我有一个福尔曼烤架大约六年了。我85%的烹饪都是在上面完成的，但我从来没有烫伤过自己，可能是因为我没有把它当枕头用。嗯，女士，我的意思是，我觉得每个人都有一个乔治·福尔曼烤架。我也有一个乔治·福尔曼烤架。
I did, too. I cooked a lot of things on it, particularly burgers. I did burgers. Yes, turkey. I would do like a turkey patty. A turkey patty, yeah. When you're a single person, it's great. It's very easy to cook for one on a George Foreman grill.
我也有。我在上面做了很多东西，特别是汉堡。我做了汉堡。是的，火鸡。我会做火鸡肉饼。火鸡肉饼，是的。当你是一个单身人士时，这很棒。在乔治·福尔曼烤架上为一个人做饭非常容易。
Yeah. Sam, you're nodding. Oh, yeah. Big George Foreman guy. Do you still have it? No, no, no. I don't have mine. Why don't I? I think it's something you grow out of in your 30s. Is that what it is? Yeah. Do people today, do the youngins today get the George Forman grill? That's a good question. Like for their dorm room and stuff? I don't know. Is it a college buy?
是的。萨姆，你在点头。哦，是的。乔治·福尔曼的忠实粉丝。你还有吗？不，不，不。我没有我的了。为什么没有？我想这是你在30多岁时会戒掉的东西。是这样吗？是的。今天的人，现在的年轻人还会买乔治·福尔曼烤架吗？这是个好问题。比如为了他们的宿舍之类的？我不知道。这是大学生的必备品吗？
Maybe? For your first apartment? I don't know. I mean, imagine what you could cook with a mini-fridge, a George Foreman grill, and a microwave. Or a hot plate as well. Well Jim cooked 85% of his meals on the George Foreman grill. Well lady, when we recorded this episode, we got into a whole conversation about how people eat string cheese. We sure did. We learned from a scene with Ryan and Toby in the kitchen
也许吧？为了你的第一个公寓？我不知道。我的意思是，想象一下你可以用一个小冰箱、一个乔治·福尔曼烤架和一个微波炉做饭。或者还有一个电热板。嗯，吉姆85%的饭菜都是在乔治·福尔曼烤架上做的。嗯，女士，当我们录制这一集时，我们进行了一场关于人们如何吃手撕奶酪的完整对话。我们确实做了。我们从瑞安和托比在厨房的场景中了解到
that Ryan just goes for it. And you know what? I do too. I just bite into it. But lady, you like to really eat it in the little stringy strips. As the name suggests. I didn't know I was such a rule breaker.
瑞安直接就咬。你知道吗？我也一样。我直接咬下去。但是，女士，你喜欢把它撕成细细的条状来吃。正如它的名字所暗示的那样。我不知道我竟然是个破坏规则的人。
Well, after this episode aired, people weighed in. We put a poll in our Instagram, and 72% of you guys string it, and 28% dive in. So clearly the stringets have it. I mean, there you go. 72% of us are normal, and 28% of people are chaos. You know what? Bring it.
嗯，这一集播出后，人们发表了意见。我们在Instagram上做了一个民意调查，72%的人选择撕着吃，28%的人直接咬。所以很明显，撕着吃的人占多数。我的意思是，你看。72%的我们是正常的，28%的人是混乱的。你知道吗？来吧。
You know what I think? Bring that chaos. Here's what I want to know. How many people who just chomp their string cheese also have 3,000 emails in their inbox? Is there a correlation? Can we do that study? Sam, do you, I can't remember if we talked about this in the breakdown, do you chomp it or string it?
你知道我在想什么吗？带来那种混乱。这是我想知道的。有多少直接咬手撕奶酪的人，收件箱里也有3000封未读邮件？这之间有相关性吗？我们可以做那个研究吗？萨姆，你，我不记得我们在细分中是否谈过这个，你是咬着吃还是撕着吃？
Oh, I string. You string. And how many emails at a time do you have in your mailbox? Unread? Yeah. Zero. Cassie? Also string it currently three unread emails.
哦，我撕着吃。你撕着吃。你的邮箱里一次有多少封邮件？未读的？是的。零。卡西？也是撕着吃，目前有三封未读邮件。
Oh, I have hit on something here. What have you hit on? Tell me. If you chomp your string cheese, you also don't look at your emails. You leave them in your inbox. You have thousands of emails unread in your inbox. Guess what else you are? What?
哦，我在这里发现了一些东西。你发现了什么？告诉我。如果你直接咬手撕奶酪，你也不看你的邮件。你把它们留在收件箱里。你的收件箱里有成千上万封未读邮件。你猜你还是什么？什么？
Not superior to others. Or are you? Guess what? Said with superiority. Guess what? You don't judge and you let people live. Live your life. But are you really living? Yes, I am.
不比别人优越。或者你是吗？你猜怎么着？带着优越感说。你猜怎么着？你不评判别人，你让人们过自己的生活。过你自己的生活。但你真的在生活吗？是的，我在生活。
With 10,000 emails, aren't you buried? No, I'm not. And isn't that wonderful? I want you to take a real good look at my face right now. This is someone who gives zero f***s. Well, I thought we could wrap up this second drink with a deleted talking head from Michael Scott. He shares how he likes to wind down after a long day.
有10000封邮件，你难道不被淹没了吗？不，我没有。这难道不美妙吗？我现在要你好好看看我的脸。这是一个完全不在乎的人。嗯，我想我们可以用迈克尔·斯科特的一个删除的谈话头来结束这第二杯酒。他分享了他如何在漫长的一天后放松。
I always keep a stash of bubble wrap in my house. Some days, hectic, tiring days, I just like to go home and zone out, click on the tube, pop a few. Very soothing. Want to try? I mean, it cracked me up and I love that he looks right at the camera operator and goes, Wanna try? Like really earnestly, like this could help you too. Oh my goodness.
我家里总是存着一些气泡膜。有些日子，忙碌、疲惫的日子，我只是想回家，放空自己，打开电视，捏几个。非常舒缓。想试试吗？我的意思是，它让我笑得前仰后合，我喜欢他直视摄像师说，“想试试吗？”就像真的很诚恳，好像这也能帮助你一样。天哪。
Oh Michael. Everyone, that is our second drink and now here is the injury. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
哦，迈克尔。各位，这就是我们的第二杯酒，现在是《受伤》。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们将拆解一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个在场的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。
Hi everybody. welcome today. We are talking about the injury. Good morning. And you know what, Angela has an injury. I do, I do, speaking of injuries. Guys, I was driving yesterday and I was chewing a piece of gum, I was popping my gum, and I bit the sh-talkie out of my tongue.
大家好。欢迎来到今天。我们正在谈论《受伤》。早上好。你知道吗，安吉拉受伤了。我确实，我确实，说到受伤。伙计们，我昨天开车时在嚼口香糖，我在吹泡泡，结果我狠狠地咬到了舌头。
It's so bad, look at it. No, it's really, it's really bad. It's a raised bump and I keep bonking it when I talk. So it's really painful. So if during this podcast, all of a sudden I go, it's cause I bonked it. Yeah. What's wrong with me?
太糟糕了，看看它。不，它真的很糟糕。它是一个凸起的肿块，我说话时总是碰到它。所以真的很疼。所以如果在这个播客期间，我突然发出声音，那是因为我碰到了它。是的。我怎么了？
I can't chew gum and drive. I was like, I was on the phone with Josh and I was like, and another thing, ah! Oh my God, it's really bad. I know, it really hurts. Okay. This episode was written by Mindy Kaling and directed by Brian Gordon.
我不能一边嚼口香糖一边开车。我当时在和乔什通电话，我说，还有一件事，啊！天哪，真的很疼。好吧。这一集是由敏迪·卡灵编剧，布莱恩·戈登执导的。
It is season two, episode 12. Wow. Yeah, so we're on the second half of season two now. There were 22 episodes in season two. We've done 18 podcasts. Yeah. When we hit 20, let's have a party. Okay.
这是第二季第12集。哇。是的，所以我们现在在第二季的后半部分了。第二季有22集。我们已经做了18个播客了。是的。当我们达到20集时，我们开个派对吧。好的。
I don't know, I'll bring cupcakes or something. Why 20? I don't know. I think we should have a party for casino night. Oh. End of season two. Let's have a party for number 23. Let's have a party every time.
我不知道，我会带纸杯蛋糕之类的。为什么是20？我不知道。我觉得我们应该为赌场之夜开个派对。哦。第二季结束。我们为第23集开个派对吧。我们每次都开个派对。
Random numbers. We don't need a reason to have a party. That's right. Let me do a summary. I can't even, I just start to look at my summary that I've written and it makes me laugh. This is one of your very favorite episodes. People should know that. You bought a shirt, Jenna, because of this episode
随机数字。我们不需要理由开派对。没错。让我做一个总结。我甚至不能，我刚开始看我写的总结，它就让我笑了。这是你最喜欢的剧集之一。人们应该知道这一点。你买了一件衬衫，珍娜，因为这一集
and you wore it all the time. I bought it off Etsy. It was a foot and a grill. And a grilled foot. It was like a comic book strip of a person grilling their foot. I mean, okay, here it is. Here's the summary. I can't even say it, it's so funny to me. Michael accidentally steps on his George Foreman grill, injuring his foot. So funny. Dwight attempts to rescue Michael and crashes his car into a pool, causing what we will find out to be a concussion.
你一直穿着它。我是在Etsy上买的。上面是一个脚和一个烤架。还有一个烤焦的脚。就像一个人在烤他的脚的漫画条。我的意思是，好吧，就是这样。这是总结。我甚至说不出来，它对我来说太搞笑了。迈克尔不小心踩到了他的乔治·福尔曼烤架，伤了他的脚。太搞笑了。德怀特试图营救迈克尔，结果把车开进了游泳池，导致了我们后来发现的脑震荡。
During the workday, the staff does not dote on Michael as he had expected, and Dwight's concussion sparks an unexpected friendship with Pam. Aw, you guys must have had so much fun doing that. Oh, I loved it. I had so many scenes, just me and Rain, and we bonded so much. Whenever you get put in a scene with someone,
在工作日期间，员工并没有像迈克尔预期的那样对他百般呵护，而德怀特的脑震荡引发了他与帕姆之间意想不到的友谊。噢，你们做那个一定很有趣。哦，我喜欢它。我有很多场景，只有我和雷恩，我们建立了深厚的感情。每当你和某人一起被安排在一个场景中，
that means you're gonna work with them for about three or four hours that day exclusively. And whenever they're, you know, having their conversations about how the scene is going or in the breaks, you get to just chitty chat. You get to just hang out. So I got to chitty chat a lot with Rain, but I just love, I also, I just love working with Rain. I mean, you were so fortunate. You got to work with him all the time. All the time. All right, should we get into the fast facts? All right, fast fact number one, this script was originally going to be called
这意味着你那天要和他们一起工作大约三到四个小时。每当他们，你知道，在休息时讨论场景进展如何，或者在休息时，你可以闲聊。你可以闲逛。所以我有很多机会和雷恩闲聊，但我只是喜欢，我也只是喜欢和雷恩一起工作。我的意思是，你太幸运了。你一直和他一起工作。一直。好吧，我们进入快讯吧？好的，快讯第一条，这个剧本最初打算叫
My Grilled Foot. My Grilled Foot, but then they changed it. So this is a standalone comedic episode that does not forward the Jim Pam storyline in any way, which was a little bit controversial because our last episode was Boo's Cruise, which was a huge bombshell confession by Jim to Michael that he is in love or that he has feelings for Pam.
《我的烤焦的脚》。《我的烤焦的脚》，但后来他们改了。所以这是一个独立的喜剧剧集，并没有以任何方式推进吉姆和帕姆的故事线，这有点争议，因为我们上一集是《酒船》，那是吉姆对迈克尔的一个巨大的重磅炸弹式的告白，说他爱上了帕姆，或者说他对帕姆有感觉。
And so everyone tuned in to see what was going to happen. And guess what? We did not answer that question in any way. In any way. So I'm sure the fans were like, what the heck? It does move forward Dwight and Angela a little bit. It does. I have that down.
所以每个人都收看节目想看看会发生什么。你猜怎么着？我们没有以任何方式回答那个问题。以任何方式。所以我敢肯定粉丝们会想，这到底是怎么回事？它确实稍微推进了德怀特和安吉拉的关系。确实。我记下来了。
It contains references to the Dwight Angela love story, which was nice. It was. I mean, we'll get to it. But there are some moments in here that I just love with Dwight Angela. I know. Me too.
它包含了对德怀特和安吉拉爱情故事的引用，这很好。确实。我的意思是，我们会讲到的。但这里面有一些时刻，我真的很喜欢德怀特和安吉拉的互动。我知道。我也是。
This was also our highest rated episode so far. What? Yeah. I think a lot of people tuned in after Boos Cruise. I think so. And what a great episode though. I mean, I know we didn't maybe give people what they were hoping to see with the cliffhanger, but we, I mean, comedy gold. We gave him comedy gold. Steve is so funny in this.
这是我们迄今为止评分最高的一集。什么？是的。我想很多人在《酒船》之后都收看了。我想也是。不过这一集真的很棒。我的意思是，我知道我们可能没有给人们他们希望看到的悬念，但我们，我的意思是，喜剧金牌。我们给了他们喜剧金牌。史蒂夫在这一集里太搞笑了。
Oh my gosh. He is the worst patient, the worst. And he made me laugh so hard. Fast fact number two. Guest star Marcus York played our building manager, Billy Merchant. Now I have to imagine this was a nod to creator of the British office, Stephen Merchant. I think that's where we grabbed that last name. Oh yeah, I didn't think about that.
天哪。他是最糟糕的病人，最糟糕的。他让我笑得太厉害了。快讯第二条。客串明星马库斯·约克饰演我们的建筑经理比利·默钱特。现在我不得不想象这是对英国版《办公室》的创作者斯蒂芬·默钱特的致敬。我想我们就是从那里抓住了那个姓氏。哦，是的，我没想过那个。
When we named Billy Merchant. I feel like that's true. I got to talk to Marcus yesterday. Marcus, thanks so much for taking time out of your day. And here are a few things he shared with me. Okay. So he auditioned for Alison, Mindy and Greg and he said it went really, really well.
当我们给比利·默钱特命名时。我觉得那是真的。我昨天和马库斯谈过了。马库斯，非常感谢你抽出时间。以下是他和我分享的一些事情。好的。所以他为艾莉森、敏迪和格雷格试镜，他说进行得非常好。
He was really excited. You know that moment where you have a great meeting or a great audition. Yeah. He said that's how it felt. He had been in LA as a working actor for a while and he said, this is one that I was like, ooh, ooh, I think I got it.
他真的很兴奋。你知道那种你有一个很棒的会议或很棒的试镜的时刻。是的。他说感觉就是那样。他在洛杉矶当了一段时间的职业演员，他说，这是我当时想，噢，噢，我想我得到了这个角色。
And he said that Greg jumped up and shook his hand. Oh. And he was like, okay. And then he was running errands. He was at Home Depot, and he got the call that he got it. And his agent was like, you got it. And he was like, wait a second. I'm in Home Depot.
他说格雷格跳起来和他握手。哦。他说，好吧。然后他去办事了。他在家得宝，接到了他得到这个角色的电话。他的经纪人说，你得到了。他说，等一下。我在家得宝。
I have to call you back. So he said he'll always remember that. And then he said the night before he had to come in, he was nervous, and he got no sleep. He said, I got zero sleep. He said, so then the next day I was freaking out because I hadn't gotten any sleep. And you know, it's like hard to remember your lines
我得回电给你。所以他说他会永远记住这一点。然后他说在他必须来的前一天晚上，他很紧张，他根本没睡。他说，我零睡眠。他说，所以第二天我吓坏了，因为我根本没睡。你知道，记住台词很难
or anything. So he was like, I was really trying to wing it. And I said, well, we couldn't tell at all. Like you were just such a cool customer. You had your lines, you were like totally ready to go. He said, and I was like going on no sleep. Oh my God. That happens to me always before a shoot. Yeah, or a big day, right? Like whenever I have a big day, it's hard to sleep.
或者任何事情。所以他说，我真的在试图临场发挥。我说，嗯，我们根本看不出来。你就像一个冷静的顾客。你有你的台词，你就像完全准备好了一样。他说，我当时根本没睡。天哪。这总是发生在我拍摄之前。是的，或者一个大日子，对吧？就像每当我有一个大日子，就很难入睡。
And then he said the thing he wasn't prepared for, and this really made me laugh. He said, the conference room is so small. Yeah. He said it's so small. And he goes, and there were so many of you in such a small room. And like him and Steve were at the front of the room having a look. So we're all looking at them, you know? Yeah. And he said, the room was so tiny. And he said, you guys had crammed so many people in there.
然后他说他没有准备好的事情，这真的让我笑了。他说，会议室太小了。是的。他说太小了。他说，你们在这么小的房间里有这么多人。就像他和史蒂夫在房间前面看一样。所以我们都在看着他们，你知道吗？是的。他说，房间太小了。他说，你们把这么多人挤在那里。
And that actually really made me laugh. And then the one other thing he said he remembered from the set, A, he said we were all really nice. Oh, that's good. That's good. But he also said the food was awesome. Yeah. He said, you guys know you had really good food, right? We did.
这真的让我笑了。然后他记得片场的另一件事，A，他说我们都很好。哦，那很好。那很好。但他还说食物太棒了。是的。他说，你们知道你们有很好的食物，对吧？我们确实有。
I was like, yeah, that is true. My dad said the same thing after visiting. He was like, man, the food. We really did. We had really good food. Aw, that is so nice. Yes, it was a delight talking to him. And I have a few other things as the episode goes.
我说，是的，那是真的。我爸爸在访问后也说了同样的话。他说，伙计，食物。我们确实有。我们有很好的食物。噢，那太好了。是的，和他谈话很愉快。随着剧集的进行，我还有其他一些事情。
OK, I love that. I love that. All right, should we do fast fact number three? Do it. I feel like I need to tell you I ran out of fast facts for this episode. What? I ran out.
好的，我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。好吧，我们做快讯第三条吗？做吧。我觉得我需要告诉你，这一集的快讯我用完了。什么？我用完了。
This is one of your favorite episodes. I know. How can you? There's only three. There's only three. How do you run out? Well, I did. And you're going to see. Here is all I could come up with. run out? Well, I did and you're gonna see,
这是你最喜欢的剧集之一。我知道。你怎么能？只有三个。只有三个。你怎么会用完？嗯，我确实用完了。你会看到的。这是我能想到的全部。用完了？嗯，我确实用完了，你会看到的，
here is all I could come up with. Drum roll. Oh, I can't, my tongue, ow. Oh, injury, injury. Go. We filmed this episode November 2005. I know this because I saved the script and it's typed on the front.
这是我能想到的全部。鼓声。哦，我不能，我的舌头，哎哟。哦，受伤，受伤。开始。我们是在2005年11月拍摄这一集的。我知道这一点，因为我保存了剧本，它打在封面上。
Okay, well, listen, as far as your delivery of that fast fact, you could have been like, guys, I saved the script. Oh, let me do it again then. Are you ready? Here's me. Fast fact number three, I saved the script. Oh my God, that's amazing. Oh yeah, that's good. That's better. See, you turned it around. That's better. Okay. Yeah. All right. Well, that's it. Let's get into it. Should we start breaking down the episode?
好吧，听着，关于你传达那个快讯的方式，你可以像，伙计们，我保存了剧本。哦，那我再做一次。你准备好了吗？这是我。快讯第三条，我保存了剧本。天哪，太棒了。哦，是的，那很好。那更好。看，你扭转了局面。那更好。好的。是的。好吧，就这样。我们开始吧。我们开始拆解这一集吗？
We usually take a break first. Okay. We haven't been talking that long. Do you want to take a break? I don't know. It's just what we usually do. I could put some numbing stuff on my tongue. I don't know how that's going to work out for the rest of the episode though.
我们通常先休息一下。好的。我们还没聊那么久。你想休息一下吗？我不知道。这只是我们通常做的。我可以在我的舌头上放一些麻木的东西。我不知道这对这一集的其余部分会有什么影响。
Be very interesting. All right. We'll be back to break down the episode. With tons of free reality shows, you are totally free to watch what you love on Pluto TV. And for me, that's Dance Moms, Bar Rescue, The Challenge, and Jersey Shore, all totally free on Pluto TV. Stream now, pay never. Hit pause on whatever you're listening to
会非常有趣。好的。我们会回来拆解这一集。有了大量的免费真人秀节目，你可以在Pluto TV上完全免费观看你喜欢的内容。对我来说，那是《舞蹈妈妈》、《吧台救援》、《挑战》和《泽西海岸》，在Pluto TV上完全免费。现在流媒体播放，永远不用付费。暂停你正在听的任何内容
and hit play on your next adventure. Stay two nights and get a $50 Best Western gift card. Life's the trip, make the most of it at Best Western. Visit bestwestern.com for complete terms and conditions. This episode is brought to you by Samsung Galaxy. Ever captured a great night video only for it to be ruined by that one noisy talker and conditions. Galaxy AI features like NowBrief will give you personalized insights based on your day schedule so that you're prepared no matter what. Buy the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra now at Samsung.com. All right, we're back talking about the injury.
并点击播放你的下一次冒险。住两晚，获得一张50美元的Best Western礼品卡。生活就是一场旅行，在Best Western充分利用它。访问bestwestern.com了解完整的条款和条件。本集由三星Galaxy为您呈现。曾经捕捉到一段很棒的夜间视频，却被那个嘈杂的说话者毁了吗？Galaxy AI功能如NowBrief将根据你的日程安排为你提供个性化的见解，这样无论发生什么，你都做好了准备。现在在Samsung.com购买三星Galaxy S25 Ultra。好的，我们回来谈论《受伤》。
Angela has an injury. Let's get started. This episode opens with what I believe is one of the greatest scenes ever in a television comedy. And I feel similarly about the opening scene of Fleabag season two as I feel about this. I haven't seen season two of Fleabag. Sorry, is this gonna be a problem in your friendship? Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
安吉拉受伤了。我们开始吧。这一集以我认为电视喜剧中最伟大的场景之一开场。我对《伦敦生活》第二季的开场场景也有类似的感觉。我还没看过《伦敦生活》第二季。抱歉，这会成为你们友谊中的问题吗？等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。
Is this a Game of Thrones moment for you? Yeah, I told you to watch it. OK, so I watched the first episode of Fleabag season one. I told you to just start with season two. Well, I don't want to start out of order. I get that, I get that, I get that. But I just need you to watch season two of Fleabag because I had an epiphany while watching it,
这对你来说是一个《权力的游戏》时刻吗？是的，我告诉过你要看它。好的，所以我看了《伦敦生活》第一季的第一集。我告诉过你直接从第二季开始。嗯，我不想乱序开始。我明白，我明白，我明白。但我只是需要你看《伦敦生活》第二季，因为我在看的时候有一个顿悟，
and it changed my life. And I think it's like the greatest season of television ever made. Okay, I want to watch it. I will watch it. I don't believe you. I don't believe you. I think if you wanted to watch it,
它改变了我的生活。我认为这是有史以来制作的最伟大的电视季。好的，我想看。我会看的。我不相信你。我不相信你。我想如果你想看的话，
you would have watched it by now. When do you watch television? I fall asleep. Like I try to put the kids to bed. Okay, we're getting off track. I, we, Lee and I watch about 45 minutes of television each night after we get the kids down. And after we, like, after I play free sell on my phone
你早就看了。你什么时候看电视？我睡着了。就像我试着让孩子们上床睡觉。好的，我们偏离轨道了。我，我们，李和我每天晚上在让孩子们睡觉后看大约45分钟的电视。在我们，就像，在我玩手机上的空当接龙之后
and he plays online poker for like 15 minutes. Oh, I'm getting, by the way, I am getting a real window. You are. Then we go downstairs and we watch either half of a movie or a TV show. That's my life, everybody. It's very routine. I will go a long time without watching television and then I will have some random day where
他玩了大约15分钟的在线扑克。哦，顺便说一句，我正在得到一个真正的窗口。你是。然后我们下楼，看半部电影或一个电视节目。这就是我的生活，各位。非常有规律。我会很长时间不看电视，然后我会有一个随机的日子，
I just binge watch three hours of TV. Well, I'm going to clear your schedule for fleabag season too. All right. It's going to change your life. All right, bossy pants. Yeah, that's right. Sometimes you have to get bossy about things and this is one of them. Okay, okay, okay, okay. All right, back to our show called The Office. This opening scene, it opens with just shots of general
我只是狂看三个小时的电视。嗯，我要为《伦敦生活》第二季清理你的日程。好的。它会改变你的生活。好的，老板。是的，没错。有时你必须对事情变得专横，这就是其中之一。好的，好的，好的，好的。好的，回到我们的节目《办公室》。这个开场场景，它以一般生活的镜头开场
office life. Michael is not in the office and apparently that has put all of us in a good mood because we're all just milling about chatting with one another when suddenly the phone rings. Pam answers the phone and this is when Michael explains that he's hurt. He needs Pam to pick him up. Jim puts him on speakerphone. The only person willing to rescue him is Dwight who runs out of the building and crashes his car. So I have the script and as I was watching this, I mean, I watched the scene, then I called Leon. He had just gotten out of the shower. I was like, he was dripping wet and I'm like,
办公室生活。迈克尔不在办公室，显然这让我们所有人都心情很好，因为我们都在闲逛，互相聊天，突然电话响了。帕姆接电话，这时迈克尔解释说他受伤了。他需要帕姆去接他。吉姆把他放在免提上。唯一愿意救他的人是德怀特，他跑出大楼，撞毁了他的车。所以我有了剧本，当我看着这个时，我的意思是，我看了这个场景，然后我给里昂打了电话。他刚洗完澡。我说，他湿透了，我说，
you have to come in and watch the scene with me again, cause it's so good. He's like, okay, can I dry off first? I was like, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. But you have to watch this brilliant bit of television comedy. So then I watched it again. I must have watched this five times.
你必须进来再和我看一遍这个场景，因为它太好了。他说，好的，我可以先擦干吗？我说，是的，是的，是的，是的。但你必须看这个精彩的电视喜剧片段。所以我又看了一遍。我一定看了五遍。
That whole insane conversation was totally scripted line for line. That opening scene is not improvised. It's awesome. That is crazy to me. The only thing that wasn't in the script was when Michael said he had a protuberance on his elbow. In the script, when Michael said he had a protuberance on his elbow. In the script, it just said, hurt my elbow. That was the only improv. But that also shows that how ready John, as Jim was, the minute Michael said that,
整个疯狂的对话完全是逐字逐句写好的。那个开场场景不是即兴创作的。太棒了。这对我来说太疯狂了。唯一不在剧本里的是迈克尔说他的肘部有一个突起。在剧本里，当迈克尔说他的肘部有一个突起时。在剧本里，它只是说，伤了我的肘部。那是唯一的即兴创作。但这也表明约翰作为吉姆是多么准备好，迈克尔说那句话的那一刻，
it wasn't in the script, John looked to camera like, okay. Yeah. I mean, what is happening there? That's great. It's fantastic. So good. Now listen, my folks who love the background, at the very top where we're all just milling about before the phone call happens, I am totally not in character. Oh, I saw it. I am just being me. You and Brian are in the background.
它不在剧本里，约翰看着镜头，就像，好的。是的。我的意思是，那里发生了什么？太棒了。太棒了。太好了。现在听着，我那些喜欢背景的人，在最上面我们都在闲逛，在电话打来之前，我完全没有进入角色。哦，我看到了。我只是做我自己。你和布莱恩在背景里。
We're goofing off. Over Oscar's shoulder. We're goofing off. Brian, I remember, did some silly like, and I swat him. Yeah. But as me, I laugh. I laugh and swat him. I totally saw it.
我们在胡闹。在奥斯卡的肩膀上。我们在胡闹。布莱恩，我记得，做了一些愚蠢的动作，我拍了他一下。是的。但作为我自己，我笑了。我笑了并拍了他一下。我完全看到了。
Yeah, it's totally me. Well, the thing is, is that Oscar is out of focus and you guys are in focus in the background. You probably thought you were safe. We probably thought the camera was on Oscar, but no, the focus was on you. Yeah. We didn't know we were on camera. I saw that, that's a really good one. That happens at five seconds. Jenna, I have a question for you.
是的，完全是我。嗯，问题是，奥斯卡失焦了，你们在背景里聚焦。你可能以为你是安全的。我们可能以为摄像机在奥斯卡身上，但没有，焦点在你身上。是的。我们不知道我们在镜头里。我看到了，那个真的很好。那发生在五秒钟。珍娜，我有一个问题要问你。
What? At 27 seconds. What? You're starting to break. I see you starting to break. Yes. I don't think so. Oh my God, totally.
什么？在27秒。什么？你开始破功了。我看到你开始破功了。是的。我不这么认为。天哪，完全是。
And then later. When? What am I doing? What is happening at 27 seconds? It's gotta be the phone call. I don't know. I didn't write it down. I should have written it down.
然后后来。什么时候？我在做什么？27秒发生了什么？一定是那个电话。我不知道。我没写下来。我应该写下来的。
How do you know I'm not acting? Everybody thought I was breaking when Dwight was in the box. Well, I think you're starting to break. But guess what? What? Later on, you full on break. I full on break in the conference room. I know.
你怎么知道我不是在演戏？当德怀特在盒子里时，每个人都以为我在破功。嗯，我觉得你开始破功了。但你猜怎么着？什么？后来，你完全破功了。我在会议室里完全破功了。我知道。
OK, but anyway, at 27 seconds, it looks like you're starting to break. Okay, I might be. At 47 seconds, we present the greatest talking head of all time. Michael's talking head explaining how he burned his foot. This too is word for word from the script, Sam, I am going to need you to pull this up.
好的，但无论如何，在27秒，看起来你开始破功了。好的，我可能是。在47秒，我们呈现了有史以来最伟大的谈话头。迈克尔的谈话头解释了他如何烧伤了他的脚。这也是剧本里的逐字逐句，萨姆，我需要你把它调出来。
Michael explains that he loves to wake up to the smell of bacon, and then he explains how he makes that happen, and it involves a George Foreman grill on the floor of his bedroom. Six strips of bacon. It's brilliant, but Steve's delivery of it, he is so, it's like,
迈克尔解释说他喜欢在培根的香味中醒来，然后他解释了他是如何做到这一点的，这涉及到一个放在他卧室地板上的乔治·福尔曼烤架。六条培根。太精彩了，但史蒂夫的表达，他太，就像，
I feel like his intention is like, okay, let me explain it to you again for everyone who can't seem to understand one last time. Right. And then also that it's like the most normal thing ever. Yeah. Like I don't, what is confusing about this? Do I need to tell you how, okay, this is how you shower. Yes. Okay, Sam, you have to find it. It's at 47 seconds. I enjoy having breakfast in bed.
我觉得他的意图是，好的，让我为那些似乎无法理解的人再解释一遍。对。然后还有这就像最正常的事情一样。是的。就像我不知道，这有什么令人困惑的？我需要告诉你怎么，好的，这就是你洗澡的方式。是的。好的，萨姆，你必须找到它。在47秒。我喜欢在床上吃早餐。
I like waking up to the smell of bacon, sue me. And since I don't have a butler, I have to do it myself. So most nights before I go to bed, I will lay six strips of bacon out on my George Foreman grill. Then I go to sleep. When I wake up, I plug in the grill. I go back to sleep again.
我喜欢在培根的香味中醒来，告我吧。既然我没有管家，我必须自己做。所以大多数晚上在我睡觉前，我会把六条培根放在我的乔治·福尔曼烤架上。然后我去睡觉。当我醒来时，我插上烤架。我又回去睡觉了。
Then I wake up to the smell of crackling bacon. It is delicious, it's good for me. It's a perfect way to start the day. Today I got up, I stepped onto the grill and it clamped down on my foot. That's it. I don't see what's so hard to believe about that. It's so good. It's so good. It's so good. Since I don't have a butler. Since I don't
然后我在噼啪作响的培根香味中醒来。它很美味，它对我很好。这是开始新的一天的好方法。今天我起床，我踩到了烤架，它夹住了我的脚。就是这样。我不明白这有什么难以置信的。太好了。太好了。太好了。既然我没有管家。既然我没有
have a butler like everybody else who wants bacon in the morning. All of the eye rolling too that he's doing, it's just like, oh. Well, he loves breakfast in bed. He loves it. This is what you have to do. Oh my gosh. I just think it's amazing. I have a- It's good for me, it's healthy. Is it? Is six strips of bacon every day. I don't know.
管家，像其他想要早上吃培根的人一样。他做的所有翻白眼，就像，哦。嗯，他喜欢在床上吃早餐。他喜欢它。这就是你必须做的。天哪。我只是觉得太神奇了。我有一个- 它对我很好，它很健康。是吗？每天六条培根。我不知道。
Fan question from C, was Steve actually on the other end of the line during the filming of the phone call? Yes, a lot of people wrote in to ask, how do we do these phone calls? We've talked a little bit about it before. Usually, they just would have someone very close off camera. Like in another room.
粉丝问题来自C，在拍摄电话时，史蒂夫真的在电话的另一端吗？是的，很多人写信来问，我们是怎么做这些电话的？我们之前谈过一点。通常，他们只是会让某人非常靠近摄像机外。就像在另一个房间里。
Yeah. When we did scenes with Melora, she was usually just in the conference room calling into Steve's office. I don't know where they put Steve here, but he was there. It was live. When he said protuberance, John could react. That is fantastic. I have a question for you.
是的。当我们和梅洛拉一起拍摄场景时，她通常只是在会议室里给史蒂夫的办公室打电话。我不知道他们把史蒂夫放在哪里，但他就在那里。它是现场的。当他说突起时，约翰可以做出反应。太棒了。我有一个问题要问你。
So during this whole exchange, we cut back to Pam's desk area. So at around 37 seconds, Jenna, there's an I heart you pillow. There's like a red Valentine's bear. What's up? What's up? This isn't the Valentine's episode. What's going on What's up? This isn't the Valentine's episode. What's going on? I don't know.
所以在这整个交流过程中，我们切回帕姆的办公桌区域。所以在37秒左右，珍娜，有一个“我爱你”的枕头。有一个红色的情人节熊。怎么了？怎么了？这不是情人节那一集。发生了什么？怎么了？这不是情人节那一集。发生了什么？我不知道。
I had those same things. I noticed that, yes, at 37 seconds, there's a really great shot at my desk. What's up with that? I also have a yoga card. Well, I gave that to you. You did? Yes. That's from you?
我有同样的东西。我注意到了，是的，在37秒，我的办公桌有一个非常好的镜头。那是怎么回事？我还有一个瑜伽卡。嗯，我给了你那个。你给了？是的。那是你给的？
That's from me. So that's one of my cards for today. So I had written you a card. I had bought those little yoga cards at Target. You know, you can get like a pack of 10. And she was had like a little pink outfit on. She was doing like down dog. And so I had written you a card on that and you kept it
那是我的。所以那是今天我的卡片之一。所以我给你写了一张卡片。我是在塔吉特买的那些小瑜伽卡。你知道，你可以买一包10张之类的。她穿着一套粉红色的衣服。她在做下犬式。所以我写了一张卡片给你，你留着它
and you had it on your desk. You know, that is so sweet. I noticed I had three Post-It notes on my desk as well. And I kept trying to pause and zoom in because I just assumed that those were probably from you too because you used to pass me Post-It that I would put on my desk. The card is from me and you kept it
你把它放在你的办公桌上。你知道，那太甜了。我注意到我的办公桌上也有三张便利贴。我一直试图暂停并放大，因为我只是假设那些可能也是你给的，因为你过去常给我便利贴，我会放在我的办公桌上。卡片是我的，你留着它
and you had it on your desk. That is too cute. And it wasn't for anything in particular. It was just, I just had written you a little card about like, I was just, I had become a series regular and we were so excited. And I had just wrote a little card about like, I was just, I had become a series regular and we were so excited and I had just wrote a little card about just like, I was so excited that we could have our lunches and all that stuff.
你把它放在你的办公桌上。那太可爱了。而且它不是为了什么特别的事情。它只是，我只是给你写了一张小卡片，关于，我只是，我成为了系列常驻演员，我们太兴奋了。我只是写了一张小卡片，关于，我只是，我成为了系列常驻演员，我们太兴奋了，我只是写了一张小卡片，关于，我只是，我太兴奋了，我们可以一起吃午餐之类的。
You guys, this is an Angela thing you should know. You still do that to this day. You love these little cards, it's so cute. And you are very good at handwriting, just messages of gratitude, mostly. Like I'm so, I have so many from you. I'm so grateful for this friendship and it's the sweetest thing about you.
你们，这是一个安吉拉的事情，你应该知道。你至今仍然那样做。你喜欢这些小卡片，太可爱了。而且你非常擅长手写，主要是感激的信息。就像我，我有很多你写的。我非常感激这段友谊，这是你最甜美的事情。
Oh, thanks. Yeah, you're really good at that. I put a note in my daughter's lunch a lot and I made one this morning. I drew a little palm tree and a beach because she loves the beach and I just put, have a great day. That's a very sweet thing about you, Angela.
哦，谢谢。是的，你真的很擅长那个。我经常在女儿的午餐里放一张纸条，我今天早上做了一张。我画了一棵小棕榈树和一个海滩，因为她喜欢海滩，我只是写了，祝你有美好的一天。这是你非常甜美的事情，安吉拉。
Well, thank you. But now looking back, I'm sure like the yoga card must've been weird, but I guess I probably just thought they were cute. No, I think because I did yoga. Didn't I do yoga? You did yoga and you brought me to a yoga class and it was one of the most painful experiences of my life.
嗯，谢谢。但现在回想起来，我肯定瑜伽卡一定很奇怪，但我猜我可能只是觉得它们很可爱。不，我想是因为我做瑜伽。我不是做瑜伽吗？你做瑜伽，你带我去了一个瑜伽课，那是我一生中最痛苦的经历之一。
Which is- Wait, but to be fair, to be fair, I had brought you to what I thought was a beginner yoga class. Well, first of all, you're like, Ang, go to yoga with me. And I said, Jenna, I've never been to yoga. I don't really get it.
这是- 等等，但公平地说，公平地说，我带你去的是我认为是初学者瑜伽课。嗯，首先，你就像，安吉，和我一起去瑜伽。我说，珍娜，我从来没去过瑜伽。我不太明白。
I'm not, I don't understand it. I don't know what any of it means. I'd have to go to a beginner beginner. Yeah. And you were like, I've got it. It's amazing. Yeah, there's this one on Tuesdays. We'll go to this beginner yoga. And you were like, I've got it. It's amazing. Yeah, there's this one on Tuesdays, we'll go to this beginner yoga class.
我不，我不明白。我不知道那意味着什么。我得去一个初学者初学者。是的。你就像，我明白了。太棒了。是的，周二有一个。我们会去这个初学者瑜伽。你就像，我明白了。太棒了。是的，周二有一个，我们会去这个初学者瑜伽课。
It'll be terrific. We waited for a day off. You took me to that yoga class. It was not the beginner class. It was so not beginner. And this woman was like militant. I thought yoga was like supposed to be like, oh, peaceful stretch.
那会很棒。我们等了一个休息日。你带我去了那个瑜伽课。那根本不是初学者课。太不是初学者了。那个女人就像好战分子。我以为瑜伽应该是像，哦，和平的伸展。
She was like, ah, ah, like she was yelling. And then she got mad at me. It was like an intermediate flow class for anyone who does yoga. And she was basically speaking a different language. It was like Shavasanas and stuff like that. I don't know what that means. I didn't know what that means. And she got really annoyed with me.
她就像，啊，啊，就像她在尖叫。然后她对我生气了。对于任何做瑜伽的人来说，那是一个中级流瑜伽课。她基本上在说一种不同的语言。就像摊尸式之类的。我不知道那意味着什么。我不知道那意味着什么。她对我真的很恼火。
Do you remember? I do. And I felt really protective of you because, and I was irritated. Then we started giggling. Yeah. Oh, and then she really didn't like that. No, but I was, I just kept thinking the whole time, what the heck? This is, explain, explain. This is beginner. But if anyone knows like yoga flow, they just shout out the poses and it goes really fast and they don't even explain what they are. And I kept raising my hand. And you're like, and I just, I was so mad and afterwards I was, oh, I was so fired up to
你记得吗？我记得。我感到非常保护你，因为，而且我很生气。然后我们开始咯咯笑。是的。哦，然后她真的不喜欢那样。不，但我当时，我整个时间都在想，这到底是怎么回事？这是，解释，解释。这是初学者。但如果有人知道瑜伽流，他们只是喊出姿势，它进行得非常快，他们甚至不解释它们是什么。我一直举手。你就像，我当时太生气了，事后我，哦，我太火大了
complain because here I had finally convinced you to go to a yoga class with me. I knew this would never happen again after this debacle. And it turns out I read the schedule wrong and it was in fact an intermediate flow class. I mean, that's what it was. When you realized that, do you remember what you did? No. You started laughing. You started laughing so hard.
抱怨，因为我终于说服你和我一起去上瑜伽课了。我知道这次惨败之后这永远不会再发生了。结果我读错了时间表，事实上那是一个中级流瑜伽课。我的意思是，就是那样。当你意识到这一点时，你记得你做了什么吗？不。你开始笑了。你开始笑得那么厉害。
You were like, oh, sorry. I was like, oh my God. But then Angela- There was a pose, wait, you guys have to know. If you've never ever, I'd never been to yoga. There was a pose where they all fricking stood on their head. They put their feet in the air and they rolled up on their shoulders, on their head. They put their feet in the air and they rolled up on their shoulders,
你就像，哦，抱歉。我当时就像，天哪。但后来安吉拉- 有一个姿势，等等，你们必须知道。如果你从来没有，我从来没去过瑜伽。有一个姿势，他们所有人都在倒立。他们把脚放在空中，他们滚到肩膀上，在头上。他们把脚放在空中，他们滚到肩膀上，
on their head and neck. I thought I was gonna die. Well, I don't know if you remember Angela, but the next day you called me and you said, I can't put my hair in a ponytail because I can't put my arms above my head. I'm so sore. I was so sore.
在他们的头上和脖子上。我以为我要死了。嗯，我不知道你还记不记得安吉拉，但第二天你给我打电话说，我没法扎马尾辫，因为我没法把胳膊抬过头顶。我太酸痛了。我当时太酸痛了。
I've never been bent that way. I was so sore. That's what she bent that way. I was so sore. And that's what she said. That's what she said. Oh, dear. That was too much. Oh, no. But I didn't go to yoga for years. It took me years to go back to yoga. This is by the way, I think a fitting tangent, another injury. I know. It might be why I gave you a card with the yoga lady on it. Maybe it was. So also on my desk, no one's going to care about this but me, but you can see this really odd plastic decoration
我从来没被那样弯曲过。我太酸痛了。这就是她被那样弯曲的原因。我太酸痛了。这就是她说的。这就是她说的。哦，天哪。那太过分了。哦，不。但我好几年没去练瑜伽了。我花了好几年才回到瑜伽课。顺便说一句，我觉得这是一个恰当的题外话，又一个伤痛。我知道。这可能就是为什么我给了你一张印有瑜伽女士的卡片。也许是吧。还有，在我的桌子上，除了我没人会在意这个，但你可以看到这个非常奇怪的塑料装饰品
behind my phone. And this decoration was on my desk for the whole nine years, and I don't know what it is. It's like a plastic base with wires coming out of it. And now on top of the wires, there are like these very colorful half spheres and they clang together if you flippity flop them. What is that for?
在我的电话后面。这个装饰品在我的桌子上放了整整九年，我不知道它是什么。它就像一个塑料底座，上面伸出几根电线。现在在电线的顶端，有像这样非常多彩的半球体，如果你拨弄它们，它们会撞在一起。那是干什么用的？
I thought that I was supposed to hold photos. I thought the spheres you put little photos in. No, there's no slot in the spheres. There's no slot in the spheres. No slot in the spheres for a photo. No slot in the spheres. No. no slot in the spheres? There's no slot in the spheres for a photo. No slot in the spheres. No. OK.
我以为它是用来夹照片的。我以为那些球体是用来放小照片的。不，球体上没有槽。球体上没有槽。球体上没有放照片的槽。球体上没有槽。不。球体上没有槽？球体上没有放照片的槽。球体上没有槽。不。好吧。
Well, I don't know what it is. If anyone wants to go to 37 seconds and look at the shot of my desk and write in and tell me what I was supposed to do with that thing on my desk, please. I thought maybe it held messages. I don't know. Why would anyone want that thing?
嗯，我不知道它是什么。如果有人想去看看37秒处我桌子的镜头，然后写信告诉我我桌子上那个东西是用来做什么的，请告诉我。我以为它可能是用来放留言的。我不知道。为什么会有人想要那个东西？
It's the same as that click clack thing that we talked about, the Newton's logic. What's it called? They're called the Newton's cradle. A Newton's cradle. Newton's balls, Newton's cradle. Well, it's the same as this weird plasticky thing, if you ask me.
它和我们谈论的那个咔哒咔哒的东西一样，牛顿的逻辑。那叫什么？它们被称为牛顿摆。一个牛顿摆。牛顿球，牛顿摆。嗯，如果你问我，它和这个奇怪的塑料玩意儿是一样的。
Okay, let me break down the car crash for everybody. Okay. Fan question, DailyBurnin said, how did Dwight driving into the pole work? Was he driving or was it someone else? I reached out to Rainn Wilson to get the full story on this. What did my tall geeky man, the love of my life, say? Here's what he said. He said, if you notice, you never actually see the crash. No. You just hear it. So they just put the car there.
好吧，让我为大家拆解一下车祸。好的。粉丝提问，DailyBurnin说，德怀特撞向电线杆是怎么拍的？是他自己在开车还是别人？我联系了雷恩·威尔逊来了解这件事的完整故事。我那高大又书呆子气的男人，我一生的挚爱，说了什么？他是这么说的。他说，如果你注意看，你其实从来没看到撞击过程。没有。你只是听到了声音。所以他们只是把车放在那里。
And he just staggered out of it. Later when he's driving away, that was a stunt driver, Rain never actually drove the car. Another fan question from Nicholas Powell, what did Rainn Wilson use for his throw up on the car? Oh, cream of potato soup. Oh. And Rainn told me it was actually his idea to throw up across the back windshield in the script.
然后他摇摇晃晃地从车里走出来。后来当他开车离开时，那是特技演员，雷恩其实从来没开过那辆车。另一个来自尼古拉斯·鲍威尔的粉丝提问，雷恩·威尔逊在车上用了什么来做呕吐物？哦，奶油土豆汤。哦。雷恩告诉我，其实是他自己提议在剧本里把呕吐物喷在后挡风玻璃上的。
And on the day he was directed to throw up on the pavement outside of the car, but he thought it would be funnier if he threw up across the back windshield. They only did about two takes, but he said he really hurt his neck. Doing the fake throw up? Yeah, because he said he had to like-
那天他被指示在车外的路面上呕吐，但他觉得如果他吐在后挡风玻璃上会更有趣。他们只拍了大约两次，但他确实说他伤到了脖子。做假呕吐的时候？是的，因为他说他必须像——
Project? Yeah, he had to like propel his neck forward so that the vomit would really splatter. And he said it was sore for like two weeks afterwards. So he got, Rainn Wilson got an injury filming the injury. I'm sorry, this is like the kind of stuff when I, I always felt like as a cast and as a show, we didn't travel well.
喷射？是的，他必须像推进他的脖子一样，这样呕吐物才能真正溅出来。他说之后酸痛了大约两个星期。所以他，雷恩·威尔逊在拍摄受伤戏份时真的受伤了。抱歉，这就是那种让我觉得，我一直觉得作为一个剧组和一部剧，我们不太擅长出外景。
Like we'd be like, safety meeting, right? We have a candle, we have fake throw up. Like, and then there's other shows with like, you know, insane explosions and car chases, but we get an injury from fake vomiting. We did, he did. I'm sorry, Rain. All right, so the next thing that happens
就像我们会说，安全会议，对吧？我们有蜡烛，我们有假呕吐物。就像，然后其他剧组有那种，你知道，疯狂的爆炸和汽车追逐，但我们却因为假呕吐而受伤。我们确实受伤了，他确实受伤了。抱歉，雷恩。好吧，接下来发生的事情
is that Michael enters on crutches and he has his foot in bubble wrap. And fan question, Nathan Jasper asked, was John popping the bubble wrap cast scripted or was that John's idea? It was scripted. It was scripted. I have a question for you, Jenna, speaking of bubble wrap.
是迈克尔拄着拐杖进来了，他的脚上裹着气泡膜。粉丝提问，内森·贾斯珀问，约翰捏气泡膜是剧本写的还是约翰的主意？是剧本写的。是剧本写的。我有一个问题要问你，珍娜，说到气泡膜。
Yeah. Not too long ago for you, Jenna, speaking of bubble wrap. Yeah. Not too long ago, you injured your foot. I did. Hiking, right? Weren't you hiking and you hurt your foot? Yeah, I did. And then you started wearing this big boot around, but then the boot started rubbing your shin.
是的。不久前，珍娜，说到气泡膜。是的。不久前，你伤到了脚。是的。徒步旅行，对吧？你当时在徒步旅行，然后伤到了脚？是的，我伤到了。然后你开始穿这只大靴子，但后来靴子开始磨你的小腿。
And then one day you showed up and I could hear like, shoo-kish, shoo-kish, shoo-kish, shoo-kish, shoo-kish. Yeah. Shoo-kish, shoo-kish, shoo-kish, shoo-kish, shoo-kish. Yeah. And I said, what is that noise? And I looked down at your boot and sticking out from your boot is bubble wrap. Yeah. So these boots, they have these like metal rods in them,
然后有一天你出现了，我能听到像，沙沙声，沙沙声，沙沙声，沙沙声，沙沙声。是的。沙沙声，沙沙声，沙沙声，沙沙声，沙沙声。是的。我说，那是什么声音？我低头看你的靴子，从靴子里伸出来的是气泡膜。是的。所以这些靴子，它们里面有像金属杆一样的东西，
which are what keep your foot stable, right? And they was like pressing into my shin. And I complained about it on Instagram. I just said, anyone who's ever worn these, like, how did you make these comfortable? Because I'm, it's like my foot feels better, but now my shin, I'm like, feel like I'm bruising my bone of my shin. Someone jokingly wrote back and said, you should wrap it in bubble wrap like Michael and I was like well I mean, that's all right bad idea and it worked It was so effective
那是用来保持你脚部稳定的，对吧？它们一直在压我的小腿。我在Instagram上抱怨过这件事。我只是说，任何穿过这些的人，你们是怎么让它变得舒服的？因为我的脚感觉好多了，但现在我的小腿，我觉得我的小腿骨都要淤青了。有人开玩笑地回信说，你应该像迈克尔那样用气泡膜把它包起来，我就想，嗯，这倒是个好主意，而且它奏效了。它太有效了。
Hot tip anyone who has to wear a boot just wrap your shin in bubble wrap. Thank you Michael Scott Thank you, Michael Scott. Thank you the injury Angela. I am very surprised that you are not calling out a Pam Sass moment. What does this card say? No, I have a previous Pam Sass. Where? No, I didn't tell them you cooked your foot. That is really good. That's some Sass.
小贴士：任何必须穿靴子的人，只要用气泡膜包住你的小腿。谢谢你，迈克尔·斯科特。谢谢你，迈克尔·斯科特。谢谢你，安吉拉，这个伤痛。我很惊讶你没有指出帕姆的刻薄时刻。这张卡片上写着什么？不，我之前有一个帕姆的刻薄时刻。在哪？不，我没告诉他们你烫伤了脚。那真的很棒。那真是够刻薄的。
I was going to say there's some Pam Sass in this episode. I have a few. I have a few. I have a few. Next up, Michael calls Pam into his office to ask for messages. Dwight is fanning Michael's foot with a tiny fan and then it buzzes his foot. And that was not in the script. We came up with that on the day. Well, I wrote, Jenna, so when that fan hits his toe, I laughed so hard because Steve's reaction was so hilarious.
我本来想说这一集里有一些帕姆的刻薄时刻。我有几个。我有几个。我有几个。接下来，迈克尔叫帕姆进办公室要留言。德怀特正用一个小风扇给迈克尔的脚扇风，然后它碰到了他的脚。那不是剧本里的。我们当天想出来的。嗯，我写了，珍娜，所以当那个风扇碰到他的脚趾时，我笑得太厉害了，因为史蒂夫的反应太搞笑了。
So good. And I, how did you keep a straight face? I didn't. Oh my God. I laughed through that entire scene. Oh my Lord. That made me laugh so hard. Don't give Rainn Wilson a tiny prop.
太棒了。我，你是怎么忍住不笑的？我没忍住。哦，天哪。我整个场景都在笑。哦，天哪。那让我笑得太厉害了。别给雷恩·威尔逊一个小道具。
Oh no. Like don't give him a keyboard at the Dundee's. They gave him that as an option to fan Michael's foot and then he just ran with it. It was so good. It's like one of my favorite things. At four minutes 22 seconds, Michael says, your job is being my friend, Pam. Yeah. And I think that's what he really thinks. It's true. And so today, I think one of the reasons he's so grumpy, that was really funny. I'm like grumpy Pam, when he's talking about like how grumpy he is, is because no one is being his friend in his mind.
哦，不。就像别在邓迪奖颁奖礼上给他一个键盘。他们给了他那个选项来给迈克尔的脚扇风，然后他就顺势发挥了。这太棒了。这是我最喜欢的事情之一。在4分22秒，迈克尔说，你的工作是做我的朋友，帕姆。是的。我觉得这就是他真实的想法。这是真的。所以今天，我觉得他这么暴躁的原因之一，那真的很有趣。我像暴躁的帕姆，当他在谈论他有多暴躁时，是因为在他看来没人是他的朋友。
That's your job. Your job isn't to answer phones. Your job is to be my friend. Friendly to me. I had a fan question from Tanya Colomarino. When Pam calls Michael fussy, was that scripted? Because it sounds like how I describe my teething babies. It was scripted.
那是你的工作。你的工作不是接电话。你的工作是做我的朋友。对我友好。我有一个来自坦尼娅·科洛马里诺的粉丝提问。当帕姆说迈克尔挑剔时，那是剧本写的吗？因为听起来像我描述我长牙的宝宝一样。那是剧本写的。
And it's perfect. It's perfect. Well, so now we're starting to see clues of Dwight's concussion, right? He clearly hit his head really hard. And there are gonna be little things sprinkled throughout the episode. And one of them is he just loses his train of thought.
而且很完美。很完美。好吧，所以现在我们开始看到德怀特脑震荡的线索了，对吧？他显然头部受到了重击。这一集里会穿插一些小细节。其中之一就是他会突然断片。
He like starts speaking. He doesn't finish his sentence. Right. Then he just starts typing Dwight over and over and over and over again. Then he like raises his hand, but he doesn't know he's raising his hand. He calls Pam Pam. It's like one of my favorite things. I just thought it was so funny. He's also friendly. He's like really friendly and he's- And helpful. Helpful. And then later on he's funny.
他开始说话。他没说完句子。对。然后他开始一遍又一遍地打字“德怀特”。然后他举起手，但他不知道自己在举手。他叫帕姆“帕姆”。这是我最喜欢的事情之一。我觉得太搞笑了。他还很友好。他真的很友好，而且——还有乐于助人。乐于助人。后来他还很搞笑。
He gets into like, that's what she said joke. He calls Creed dad. Yes, he thinks Creed is his dad. At one point he gets weepy. Yeah. This is what happens when Dwight gets a concussion. I have a fan question from Lucy. Was Rainn Wilson actually typing Dwight over and over?
他开始说“这就是她说的”笑话。他叫克里德“爸爸”。是的，他以为克里德是他爸爸。有一次他变得多愁善感。是的。这就是德怀特脑震荡后发生的事情。我有一个来自露西的粉丝提问。雷恩·威尔逊真的在一遍又一遍地打字“德怀特”吗？
Ooh, was he? Yes, I asked Rainn. He said yes, he was really typing Dwight. But that made me think about how a lot of times we would have those prop computer document things that the props department would have some computer programmer coder come up with. So if you did have to type something specific that they were gonna show on the screen you could actually just press anything and then the
哦，他是吗？是的，我问了雷恩。他说是的，他真的在打字“德怀特”。但这让我想到，很多时候我们会有那些道具电脑文档，道具部门会让一些电脑程序员写出来。所以如果你确实需要打一些他们要在屏幕上展示的特定内容，你其实可以随便按任何键，然后
sentence would come up I always liked those I thought they were really fun yeah or if like Pam had to I don't know like if you clicked on certain things websites would come up but they were all fake websites and it was like a movie it was just like a slideshow of documents. And then you would hit escape and it would start over for the next take. Yeah, and it wouldn't matter what key you hit. Didn't matter. Didn't matter.
句子就会出来。我一直很喜欢那些，我觉得它们很有趣。是的，或者如果帕姆需要，我不知道，如果你点击某些东西，网站就会出来，但它们都是假网站，就像电影一样，只是文档的幻灯片。然后你按退出键，它就会为下一条拍摄重新开始。是的，你按什么键都无所谓。无所谓。无所谓。
But he was really typing Dwight. At five minutes, 44 seconds, you guys, there's now a sofa in the conference room. Yes. Where did this sofa come from? I have that. Okay, and then also, is it the only time there's a sofa ever in the conference room? That I don't know.
但他确实在打字“德怀特”。在5分44秒，伙计们，会议室里现在有一张沙发。是的。这张沙发是从哪来的？我有那个。好的，还有，这是会议室里唯一一次出现沙发吗？我不知道。
Okay. But it is the sofa from Front Reception. And I read the script and this is a description from the script that I absolutely love, so I'm going to read it. It says, so Michael moves into the conference room and it says, Michael is splayed out on a sofa, the one by Pam's desk, which has been moved and is cuddled up under a comforter with his leg elevated.
好的。但它是前台的那张沙发。我读了剧本，这是剧本中我非常喜欢的一段描述，所以我读一下。它说，迈克尔搬进了会议室，它说，迈克尔瘫在沙发上，就是帕姆桌子旁边的那张，已经被搬走了，他蜷缩在一条被子里，腿垫高了。
It says, though he made the conference room his bedroom, it's unclear if he's wearing his pants under the comforter. That's something Mindy wrote. So however, I love that though, however they set that scene, they had to make it so that it was unclear. Yeah. He did walk in though with a duvet comforter and two pillows and then a few sort of it looks like aloe vera and some ointments that he had. All right, a ton of people wrote in about this conspiracy theory
它说，虽然他把会议室当成了卧室，但不清楚他在被子下面有没有穿裤子。那是敏迪写的。所以，无论如何，我喜欢那个，无论他们怎么布置那个场景，他们必须让它看起来不清楚。是的。他确实带着一条羽绒被和两个枕头走了进来，还有一些看起来像芦荟和一些他有的药膏。好吧，很多人写信来讨论这个阴谋论
that Steve had a prop foot that he propped up on the pillow and they sent these pictures that seem to imply that his body is doing something that a normal human body couldn't do. No, that's Steve's foot. That is Steve's foot. But I got so many emails and so many comments about it. That's crazy.
说史蒂夫有一个道具脚，他把它垫在枕头上，他们发来的这些照片似乎暗示他的身体在做正常人类身体做不到的事情。不，那是史蒂夫的脚。那是史蒂夫的脚。但我收到了很多关于它的电子邮件和评论。太疯狂了。
That I started, I mean, we were there. We know there was no fake foot on a pillow. But the pictures were so convincing, and we'll post this on our website so you can see, they were so convincing that I reached out to Steve. Oh my god, Jenna. I bothered Steve Gorell. You were like, Steve, is that your foot?
以至于我开始，我的意思是，我们在那里。我们知道枕头上没有假脚。但这些照片太有说服力了，我们会把这个发到我们的网站上，这样你就能看到，它们太有说服力了，以至于我联系了史蒂夫。哦，天哪，珍娜。我打扰了史蒂夫·戈雷尔。你当时说，史蒂夫，那是你的脚吗？
And he's like, what are you talking about? I'm guessing. He's like, he's like, first of all, hi, Jenna. I hope you're well. Yeah, that was my foot. I wrote Steve this email message. It was like 11 PM. I was like, Steve, I feel like I know the answer to this.
他说，你在说什么？我猜。他说，首先，你好，珍娜。希望你一切都好。是的，那是我的脚。我给史蒂夫发了这封电子邮件。当时大约是晚上11点。我说，史蒂夫，我觉得我知道这个问题的答案。
And I sort of explained it. And also I'm not drunk. And he wrote back and he's like, is this what it's come to? No. This is what we talk about on the podcast. And he was like, it was not a fake foot. It was my foot.
我解释了一下。而且我没喝醉。他回信说，事情已经发展到这一步了吗？不。这就是我们在播客里谈论的内容。他说，那不是假脚。那是我的脚。
It was his foot. I even remember him having to go special to hair and makeup because they put those divots on the bottom. The grill marks. The grill marks. That was like special like effects makeup. Yeah, a lot of people asked how they did that. There's like this putty that they use to make those
那是他的脚。我甚至记得他必须专门去化妆间，因为他们在底部放了那些凹痕。烤架痕迹。烤架痕迹。那是像特效化妆一样的东西。是的，很多人问他们是怎么做到的。有一种他们用来制作那些东西的油灰
and they glue it on your foot with a special glue. And then they like- Spirament glue or something like that. It is called like spirament glue. But then they like, they'll like use like this airbrush makeup machine and then to make it blend and then they'll stipple. It's pretty-
他们用一种特殊的胶水把它粘在你的脚上。然后他们像——螺旋胶之类的东西。它确实叫螺旋胶之类的。但后来他们会像使用这种喷枪化妆机，然后让它融合，然后他们会点涂。这相当——
Highlight on it. It's pretty amazing. Did you say stipple? Stipple. That is what it's called. A stipple sponge. It is. Yeah, did you not stipple sponge. It is, yeah. Did you not take like theater makeup 101?
高光在上面。这相当神奇。你说点涂？点涂。那就是它的名字。点涂海绵。确实是。是的，你没上过戏剧化妆101吗？
Watch yourself. Well, in my theater training, No, I didn't. We had to buy a Ben Nye makeup kit, which included a stipple sponge. Well, I was doing comedy. I was doing improv on stage while you were playing with your sponge.
小心点。嗯，在我的戏剧训练中，不，我没有。我们必须买一套本·奈化妆套件，其中包括一块点涂海绵。嗯，我在做喜剧。我在舞台上做即兴表演，而你在玩你的海绵。
Okay, all right. At five minutes, 50 seconds, the Prism Duro Sport. Yeah, Pam's iPod knockoff gift from Roy. That Dwight says is chunkier and more solid than an iPod. Way to go. Because that's what you want. Way to go, Roy. You get her the cluster ring
好吧，好吧。在5分50秒，Prism Duro Sport。是的，罗伊送给帕姆的iPod山寨礼物。德怀特说它比iPod更厚实、更坚固。干得好。因为这就是你想要的。干得好，罗伊。你给她买了簇状戒指
and then you get her a Prism Duro Sport. Way to go, Roy. So I did a deep dive on the Prism Duro Sport. Lady, me too. Lady, lady. What did you find? Not only what did I find, because I know you found it too,
然后你给她买了一个Prism Duro Sport。干得好，罗伊。所以我对Prism Duro Sport进行了深入研究。女士，我也是。女士，女士。你发现了什么？不仅是我发现了什么，因为我知道你也发现了，
but I printed it out and I brought it. You brought the fake website for the Prism Duro Sport? First of all, the fake website is called durosport.com. It's still up. You can still find it. These were- Who made it? Our writers. Okay, first of all, the fake website is called durosport.com. It's still up. You can still find it. These were- Who made it? I couldn't- Our writers.
但我把它打印出来带过来了。你带了Prism Duro Sport的假网站？首先，这个假网站叫durosport.com。它还在运行。你仍然可以找到它。这些是——谁做的？我们的编剧。好的，首先，这个假网站叫durosport.com。它还在运行。你仍然可以找到它。这些是——谁做的？我不能——我们的编剧。
No, they did not. Yes, they did. Our writers took the time to make this. Yes. How? Clearly, they were just having some fun. We should probably talk to them. They made up durosport.com.
不，他们没有。是的，他们做了。我们的编剧花时间做了这个。是的。怎么做到的？显然，他们只是在找乐子。我们可能应该和他们谈谈。他们编造了durosport.com。
Then they went one step further and they made a review site that reviewed the Prism DuraSport and it's called Media Loper. What? I printed out. This I did not find. I printed out the review of the DuraSport. Oh please. It's the Prism DuraSport 6000 worst digital audio player ever.
然后他们更进一步，做了一个评论网站，评论了Prism DuraSport，它叫Media Loper。什么？我打印出来了。这个我没发现。我打印出了DuraSport的评论。哦，拜托。它是Prism DuraSport 6000，有史以来最糟糕的数字音频播放器。
And it goes on. You guys, this thing is, oh my gosh, I printed out, it is 11 pages. It is- Can we put links on our- Yes, on our website. On our website, officeladies.com, look for all this stuff. Look, there's the photo of it.
它还在继续。伙计们，这个东西，哦天哪，我打印出来了，它有11页。它是——我们能把链接放在我们的——是的，在我们的网站上。在我们的网站上，officeladies.com，寻找所有这些东西。看，那是它的照片。
It looks ridiculous. But here's one of my favorite things. At the end of this horrible review, there is a comment board. And they made fake comments? They made fake comments, which is so funny. You have to read the fake comments. They're some of my favorites.
它看起来很荒谬。但这是我最喜欢的事情之一。在这个糟糕的评论结尾，有一个评论板。他们做了假评论？他们做了假评论，这太搞笑了。你必须读读那些假评论。它们是我最喜欢的一些。
And the very, very last fake comment, if you go all the way to the end, it says, it's by Shilkote. Okay. Why do I feel like that's Mike Schur? Is that Shilkote says, "'To anyone who doesn't know, "'DuroSport is in fact a joke. It was created by the writers of The Office. Check the who is. It went up soon after the episode air.
最后一个假评论，如果你一直读到最后，它说，是Shilkote写的。好的。为什么我觉得那是迈克·舒尔？是Shilkote说，“对于任何不知道的人，DuroSport其实是个笑话。它是由《办公室》的编剧创作的。查查whois。它在剧集播出后不久就上线了。”
Wow. Our writers were really having a good time with this. I guess so. I have a fan question from Steph. Was Pam's device a CreativeZen MP3 player? She calls it something else but it really looks like a CreativeZen. So there is, I mean, Phil Shea had to hand me something and it really worked. I could really scroll and it really plugged into my computer. So I froze the image at five minutes, 47 seconds, and I compared it to an image of a creative zen, I think Steph might be right. Nice catch Steph, I'm giving you applause. Yeah, so I guess if you want to own one, they have them on eBay. Also fan comment from Jamie Garrett just said, comment, this is not a question.
哇。我们的编剧真的玩得很开心。我想是的。我有一个来自斯蒂芬的粉丝提问。帕姆的设备是CreativeZen MP3播放器吗？她叫它别的名字，但它看起来真的很像CreativeZen。所以，我的意思是，菲尔·谢必须递给我一些东西，它真的能用。我真的可以滚动，它真的能插进我的电脑。所以我把画面定格在5分47秒，我把它和CreativeZen的图像进行了比较，我觉得斯蒂芬可能是对的。好眼力，斯蒂芬，我为你鼓掌。是的，所以我想如果你想拥有一个，他们在eBay上有卖。还有来自杰米·加勒特的粉丝评论，只是说，评论，这不是问题。
I can verify that there was actually a Russian music website with 10 cent downloads. I used it for years until sanctions against Russia shut it down. So Dwight is giving Pam some good advice. I totally believe that. At six minutes, 48 seconds, some major Pam sass. Pam sass. Pam sass. Michael's like, will you come in here?
我可以证实确实有一个俄罗斯音乐网站，下载费只要10美分。我用了好几年，直到针对俄罗斯的制裁关闭了它。所以德怀特给了帕姆一些好的建议。我完全相信这一点。在6分48秒，一些重大的帕姆刻薄时刻。帕姆刻薄时刻。帕姆刻薄时刻。迈克尔说，你过来这里好吗？
And she goes, tell me before I come there. Now that feels like such justified sass. It's justified sass, but it's also how I talk to my children. When they're like, mom, I'm like, what? Tell me. If I come all the way upstairs, I want to know what this is about. But then he asks her to rub butter on his foot.
她说，在我过去之前先告诉我。现在这感觉像是非常合理的刻薄。这是合理的刻薄，但这也是我跟我的孩子们说话的方式。当他们说，妈妈，我就说，什么？告诉我。如果我要一直走上楼，我想知道这是关于什么的。但后来他让她把黄油涂在他的脚上。
Gross. Country croc. And she just says no and hangs up on him. I had a question about that. Is country croc in the script? Because it sounded like an improv. No, Country Croc was not in the script. What happens after Pam hangs up with him is that Meredith was supposed to come over and offer to do it. And Michael says something like, oh, blech, no. And she says, I'm telling you, Michael, I have really soft hands.
恶心。Country Croc。她只是说不，然后挂了他的电话。我对此有个问题。Country Croc是剧本里的吗？因为听起来像即兴表演。不，Country Croc不是剧本里的。帕姆挂断电话后发生的事情是，梅雷迪思本应走过来主动提出做这件事。迈克尔说了一些类似的话，哦，呸，不。她说，我告诉你，迈克尔，我的手真的很软。
So there was a little like extra little beat. That's what happened after he didn't say country croc. Well, when I watched it and Steve, as Michael said, country croc, you sort of get to know each other and you can sort of tell when something, I was like, that is all Steve. That sounds like an improv to me. So at seven minutes, 31 seconds in the scene at reception
所以有一个额外的小节拍。这就是他没说Country Croc之后发生的事情。嗯，当我观看它时，史蒂夫作为迈克尔说，Country Croc，你们会互相了解，你可以看出什么时候有些东西，我就想，那全是史蒂夫。听起来像即兴表演。所以在7分31秒，在接待处的场景
when Dwight is showing Pam that she can throw her music thing and it won't break. Did you notice at the end of the scene what Rain as Dwight does? He taps the desk the way Jim always does. Yes, as he walked off. Yeah, that was a little bit that Rain and I came up with on the day. That is so great.
当德怀特向帕姆展示她可以扔掉她的音乐设备而且它不会坏时。你注意到场景结束时雷恩作为德怀特做了什么吗？他像吉姆总是做的那样拍了拍桌子。是的，当他走开的时候。是的，那是我和雷恩当天想出来的一点小动作。那太棒了。
That's so subtle. I love it. Yeah, it's so subtle. I love it. Yeah, it's really cute. I love it. Well, I have at seven minutes, 38 seconds. Is Jim jealous? I can't believe it. Jim is a little bit jealous of Dwight because Dwight is having his Pam moments.
那太微妙了。我喜欢它。是的，太微妙了。我喜欢它。是的，真的很可爱。我喜欢它。嗯，我有在7分38秒。吉姆嫉妒了吗？我不敢相信。吉姆有点嫉妒德怀特，因为德怀特正在拥有他的帕姆时刻。
Yeah. Pam and Dwight are friends now. And at seven minutes, 43 seconds, I have my very famous line that gets quoted to me a lot. Oh my God, Dwight is kind of my friend. How about the scene where Michael is in the conference room and he's on the phone with his mom? It's one of my favorite scenes.
是的。帕姆和德怀特现在是朋友了。在7分43秒，我有我那句非常著名的台词，经常被人引用。哦，天哪，德怀特算是我的朋友。迈克尔在会议室里和他妈妈通电话的那个场景怎么样？那是我最喜欢的场景之一。
It is one of my favorite scenes. It is so layered with so much. He's like, no one cares. And then he's sort of like clearly lied to his mom about him and Jan. And he was like, oh, she'll have to drive, she'll worry. And then, then he finds out that Pam and his mom have been chatting and Pam has built in his mom on his relationship status. And he gets so ticked off.
那是我最喜欢的场景之一。它充满了如此多的层次。他说，没人关心。然后他显然对他妈妈撒了关于他和简的谎。他说，哦，她得开车，她会担心的。然后，然后他发现帕姆和他妈妈一直在聊天，帕姆把他的感情状况告诉了他妈妈。他气坏了。
I love this whole conversation. It was so great. That was all scripted. Oh, it's so good, Mindy. But look at all the people milling around in the background. I know. There were so many crosses. What are we ever up from our desks like that? Why? What so much activity?
我喜欢整个对话。太棒了。那全是剧本写的。哦，太好了，敏迪。但看看背景里走来走去的所有人。我知道。有太多的交叉走动。我们什么时候会像那样离开我们的办公桌？为什么？为什么有这么多活动？
I'm not I'm not even at reception. I'm like doing something. What am I doing in that corner? You know what that moment was when I watched it? That's Brian Gordon. I think that's the director. And he wanted a bunch of us, like he wanted movement in the back of the scene.
我甚至不在接待处。我像是在做某事。我在那个角落里做什么？你知道那个时刻是什么吗，当我观看它的时候？那是布莱恩·戈登。我想那是导演。他想要我们中的一群人，就像他想要场景背景中有动作。
Well, if I remember correctly, there was this idea that he had where because Steve was stuck, he wanted it to seem like that was like a FOMO. Like he wasn't out there with us. He wasn't walking around with us and like joking with us and that he couldn't be part of what that was happening out there. Look at you using the kids lingo.
嗯，如果我没记错的话，他有一个想法，因为史蒂夫被困住了，他想让它看起来像是一种错失恐惧症（FOMO）。就像他没和我们在一起。他没和我们一起走动，也没和我们一起开玩笑，他不能成为外面发生的事情的一部分。看看你用孩子们的流行语。
FOMO? FOMO. Is that the kids lingo? A little bit. All right guys, I'm gonna read to you from a journal. I wrote about the scene of Rain and I in the break room. So you're going to hear some journal thoughts from Angela. Journal thoughts after the break. At Desjardins, we speak business. We speak equipment modernization. We're fluent in data digitization and expansion into foreign markets
FOMO？FOMO。那是孩子们的流行语吗？有一点。好吧，伙计们，我要给你们读一篇日记。我写了关于雷恩和我休息室场景的日记。所以你们会听到一些安吉拉的日记想法。休息后的日记想法。在Desjardins，我们谈论商业。我们谈论设备现代化。我们精通数据数字化和向外国市场扩张
And we can talk all day about streamlining manufacturing processes because at Desjardins business We speak the same language you do business So join the more than 400,000 Canadian entrepreneurs who already count on us and contact Desjardins today We'd love to talk business. Sick of dreaming smaller? Sick of investing but not seeing your money grow? Sick of feeling like you're leaving money on the table, paying high fees, and not knowing if you're even making the right investments? With Questrade, you get the right tools, stock insights, and proper guidance so you can become a better investor.
我们可以整天谈论精简制造流程，因为在Desjardins商业，我们说的是和你一样的语言，商业。所以加入已经依赖我们的40万多名加拿大企业家，今天就联系Desjardins。我们很乐意谈论商业。厌倦了梦想太小？厌倦了投资却看不到钱增长？厌倦了感觉自己错失了机会，支付高额费用，却不知道自己是否做出了正确的投资？有了Questrade，你就能获得正确的工具、股票见解和适当的指导，这样你就能成为更好的投资者。
It's time to get the financial future you deserve. Get yours, Questrade. Looking to simplify? How about the simple sounds of neutral vodka soda with zero gram sugar per can for the next 15 seconds. Neutral. Refreshingly simple. We're back everyone from our break and it's time for Angela's Diary. Every time you say that, she's been saying that during the break you guys.
是时候获得你应得的财务未来了。获得你的，Questrade。想简化吗？中性伏特加苏打水的简单声音怎么样，每罐零克糖，接下来的15秒。中性。清爽简单。我们休息回来啦，现在是安吉拉的日记时间。每次你说那个，你在休息期间一直在说那个，伙计们。
Angela's Diary. It just sounds like something brought to you by PBS, Angela's Diary. So the scene in the break room with Dwight and Angela. Some Dwangela. Some Dwangela. Some weird love. Well, he tells her that she's sweeter than candy, and then he pats her butt.
安吉拉的日记。听起来就像PBS带来的东西，安吉拉的日记。所以休息室里德怀特和安吉拉的场景。一些Dwangela。一些Dwangela。一些奇怪的爱。嗯，他告诉她她比糖果还甜，然后他拍了拍她的屁股。
He does. Angela wrote about it in her diary, you guys. I wrote about it in my journal. Your journal. So all right, I say a few things about that break room scene between Dwight and Angela. We filmed a lot of different versions. Pretty much they just wanted Rain to surprise me in some way
他确实拍了。安吉拉在她的日记里写了这件事，伙计们。我在我的日记里写了这件事。你的日记。所以好吧，我说了几件关于德怀特和安吉拉休息室场景的事情。我们拍了很多不同的版本。基本上他们只是想让雷恩以某种方式给我惊喜
and that I would have like this natural reaction. And we knew that he was gonna do something and then kind of run off, right? So I have here Rain spanked me, swatted me, tried to kiss me. One time he actually picked me up by my butt, which, whoa. So I remember he like ran up behind me and kind of grabbed me and I sort of leaned back and he lifted up at the same time.
而我会像有这种自然的反应。我们知道他会做点什么，然后跑掉，对吧？所以我这里有雷恩拍了我，打了我的屁股，试图亲我。有一次他真的把我的屁股提了起来，这，哇。所以我记得他像从我身后跑过来，抓住了我，我向后倾，他同时向上提。
We weren't planning this guys. This was just like a kind of random accident but it was so weird that he just sort of lifted me by my buttocks. So that one didn't make it in. Anyway, we did a bunch of takes and I said that I laughed so much. We were laughing so much that I was really surprised
我们没计划这个，伙计们。这只是像一种随机的意外，但太奇怪了，他竟然用我的臀部把我提了起来。所以那个没用上。无论如何，我们拍了很多次，我说我笑得太厉害了。我们笑得太厉害了，以至于我很惊讶
they found one they could use. Because I didn't know what he was gonna do. And you know Rain? Rain is like gonna throw you curve balls. He actually delights in that. Of course. He loves it. Like he loves to throw you off.
他们找到了一个能用的版本。因为我不知道他会做什么。而且你知道雷恩吗？雷恩就像会给你投曲线球。他其实以此为乐。当然。他喜欢这样。就像他喜欢让你措手不及。
But ultimately we use the one where he swatted me a punch and just ran away. In the script it said he squeezes your butt. Did you do some squeezes? I'm sure. I'm sure there was squeezes, swats. I mean, I did write that like I had a little bruise on my butt the next day.
但最终我们用了他拍了我一下然后跑掉的那个版本。剧本里说他捏了你的屁股。你做了一些捏的动作吗？我肯定。我肯定有捏、拍。我的意思是，我确实写了我第二天屁股上有一点淤青。
That was just too much touching your butt? Anyway, that's what I wrote there. Well, the next scene, Michael is trying to enter the kitchen. Ryan does not help him because he is busy eating string cheese with Toby. Which I loved that interaction. I did too. When Ryan's like, oh, you just go for it. You don't pull it apart.
那是因为摸你的屁股太多了吗？无论如何，我写在那儿了。嗯，下一个场景，迈克尔试图进入厨房。瑞安没有帮他，因为他正忙着和托比吃手撕奶酪。我喜欢那个互动。我也喜欢。当瑞安说，哦，你直接吃就行了。你不用把它撕开。
I love that. That was actually Toby says that to Ryan. I know. You just go for it. Did I say Ryan? Yeah, you said Ryan. That's all right. God, I that to Ryan. I know you just go for it. Did I say Ryan? Yeah, you said Ryan. That's right.
我喜欢那个。其实是托比对瑞安说的。我知道。你直接吃就行了。我说了瑞安吗？是的，你说了瑞安。没关系。天哪，我那是对瑞安说的。我知道你直接吃就行了。我说了瑞安吗？是的，你说了瑞安。那是对的。
Oh God, I'm so embarrassed. I'm embarrassed for myself. Please, we'll issue a correction. Angela, how do you eat string cheese? Do you go for it or do you string it? I go for it. I string it. Ah, this says everything about us.
哦天哪，我太尴尬了。我为自己感到尴尬。拜托，我们会发布更正。安吉拉，你怎么吃手撕奶酪？你是直接吃还是把它撕开？我直接吃。我把它撕开。啊，这说明了一切关于我们。
You probably methodically, you have a system of how you eat your string cheese. You know, I get so mad if my string is too thick. Like I like to really string it. Do you get mad at yourself, Jenna? Well, yeah, I like it to be like even strings. Okay, I open it and just bite it off. This says everything about us, I feel like.
你可能很有条理，你有一套吃手撕奶酪的系统。你知道，如果我的丝太粗，我会很生气。我喜欢真正把它撕开。你对自己生气吗，珍娜？嗯，是的，我喜欢它像均匀的丝。好的，我打开它然后直接咬掉。我觉得这说明了一切关于我们。
I don't have time to string it out. Guys, how do you eat your string cheese? Yeah, we wanna know. Will you comment us? Do you string it or do Guys, how do you eat your string cheese? Yeah, we wanna know. Will you comment us? Do you string it or do you bite it? Or do you bite it? Jen is a stringer, I'm a biter. I'm gonna do a poll and we'll tell you the results.
我没时间把它撕开。伙计们，你们怎么吃手撕奶酪？是的，我们想知道。你们会评论我们吗？你们是撕开它还是——伙计们，你们怎么吃手撕奶酪？是的，我们想知道。你们会评论我们吗？你们是撕开它还是咬它？或者你们咬它？珍娜是撕开派，我是咬派。我要做一个民意调查，然后告诉你们结果。
Okay. So Michael eventually makes it into the bathroom and then you overhear him falling into the toilet, demanding that Pam help him, demanding that Ryan help him, demanding that Ryan help him. This was all basically scripted except for, it was in the script that Michael is supposed to say, get Ryan. But then Steve improvised, he needs to lift me and he needs to clean me up a little bit, bring a wet towel. And I think you can see Paul start to break at the end.
好的。所以迈克尔最终进了洗手间，然后你听到他掉进马桶里，要求帕姆帮他，要求瑞安帮他，要求瑞安帮他。这基本上全是剧本写的，除了剧本里迈克尔应该说，叫瑞安。但后来史蒂夫即兴发挥，他需要扶我，他需要帮我清理一下，拿条湿毛巾。我觉得你可以看到保罗在最后开始破功了。
Oh no, you totally can. I froze this. I watched the scene a few times cause I was like, Paul is breaking. Paul is breaking at nine minutes, 46 seconds. He starts to laugh and he turns away from camera and kind of leaves. He does.
哦不，你完全可以。我定格了。我看了几次这个场景，因为我在想，保罗破功了。保罗在9分46秒破功了。他开始笑，然后转过身背对镜头，然后离开了。他确实离开了。
And then the camera, cause our camera guys would do this quite often for us. When they would see that we were starting to break, they'd whip away from us. They would. So he whipped, the camera guy whipped to the door. Our camera guys would do this quite often for us when they would see that we were starting to break, they'd whip away from us. So he whipped, the camera guy whipped to the door. But I think the thing that did him in was when you hear Michael fall for the second time because that was also not in the script and I think it was too much for Paul.
然后镜头，因为我们的摄影师经常为我们这样做。当他们看到我们开始破功时，他们会迅速移开镜头。他们确实会。所以他迅速，摄影师迅速移向门口。我们的摄影师经常为我们这样做，当他们看到我们开始破功时，他们会迅速移开镜头。所以他迅速，摄影师迅速移向门口。但我认为让他破功的是当你听到迈克尔第二次摔倒的时候，因为那也不是剧本里的，我觉得这对保罗来说太过分了。
Well Steve was in there clanging around like making noises and stuff. It was very funny. All right, so next, Jim and Pam are out in the bullpen and they're discussing Dwight. And this is when Michael busts in and asks people if they know what it's like to have a disability. He's ticked off. I remember shooting that scene. He is so angry now that no one is taking care of him
嗯，史蒂夫在里面叮叮当当地发出声音之类的。非常有趣。好吧，所以接下来，吉姆和帕姆在办公区，他们在讨论德怀特。这时迈克尔闯进来，问大家是否知道残疾是什么感觉。他气坏了。我记得拍摄那个场景。他现在非常生气，因为没人照顾他
or treating him special. And a lot of fans mentioned that one of their favorite lines is Stanley's line when Michael says, what does this look like to you? And Stanley says mailboxes, et cetera. And then Steve does that thing that I love where he's like, shut it. That's Steve right there.
或者对他进行特殊对待。很多粉丝提到他们最喜欢的台词之一是斯坦利的台词，当迈克尔说，这看起来像什么？斯坦利说，邮箱等等。然后史蒂夫做了我喜欢的那种动作，他说，闭嘴。那就是史蒂夫。
So you know at the end of that scene, Dwight turns to Creed and says, Dad, that was added on the day. That was an improv on the day. It was probably an alt. They would do that to us sometimes. They would have alternate endings to scenes. In the script, Dwight was supposed to pick up his phone and say hello, even though it
所以你知道在那个场景结束时，德怀特转向克里德说，爸爸，那是当天加进去的。那是当天的即兴表演。那可能是一个备选方案。他们有时会那样对我们。他们会有场景的备选结局。在剧本里，德怀特本应拿起电话说喂，即使它
didn't ring. Well, Creed being his dad is way better. Perfect, perfect. All right, so this moves us into the conference room meeting, where Michael has hung a bunch of photos of disabled people on the wall. Icons. Icons. Yes.
没响。嗯，克里德是他爸爸好多了。完美，完美。好吧，所以这把我们带到了会议室会议，迈克尔在墙上挂了一堆残疾人的照片。偶像。偶像。是的。
Including two pictures of Tom Hanks. Tom Hanks in Forrest Gump, and then Tom Hanks in Big. Yeah. But he thinks it's in Philadelphia. And then there was like a debate that it's definitely big. It's definitely big, but he says it still counts because he became a man overnight, which is a type of disability.
包括两张汤姆·汉克斯的照片。汤姆·汉克斯在《阿甘正传》里，还有汤姆·汉克斯在《飞越未来》里。是的。但他以为是在《费城故事》里。然后有一场辩论，它绝对是《飞越未来》。它绝对是《飞越未来》，但他说是的，这仍然算数，因为他一夜之间变成了一个男人，这是一种残疾。
11 minutes, 56 seconds, tracking Mindy. Her hair looks fantastic. Her hair is fantastic. I have it on a note card, but it is half up and half down. It is, it's not full down. Her sweater, she's got a little bit of a V-neck. Yeah. We're not up to her chin
11分56秒，追踪敏迪。她的头发看起来棒极了。她的头发棒极了。我把它写在笔记卡上了，它是半扎半放的。是的，不是全放下来。她的毛衣，她有一点V领。是的。我们不再到她的下巴了
with these like turtleneck blouses anymore. Paisley tops. She does have a paisley skirt. Speaking of hairstyles, Jenna, I wrote about my hair in my journal for this episode. I am just. What? Listen, lady, if you had had to wear a tight bun
穿着这些高领衬衫。佩斯利花纹上衣。她确实有一条佩斯利花纹裙子。说到发型，珍娜，我在我的日记里写了关于这一集的头发。我只是。什么？听着，女士，如果你不得不穿一个紧紧的发髻
with a gazillion bobby pins poking you for like every day, you would definitely, if something changed, you might write about it, and I did. So here we go. This is what I said. On a small note, I for once like my hair in this episode. Angela always wears the crazy braids, the buns, the ponytails, but I guess being in a relationship has made her step it up a little. Ooh, I like that backstory.
每天都有无数的发夹扎着你，你肯定，如果有什么改变，你可能会写下来，我确实写了。所以我们开始吧。这是我说的。顺便提一下，我这一集里难得喜欢我的头发。安吉拉总是梳着疯狂的辫子、发髻、马尾辫，但我猜恋爱关系让她稍微提升了一下。哦，我喜欢那个背景故事。
I got to wear my hair down. You did. And I was really excited. It had a little bit of a bouffant. I actually thought your hair looked really pretty in this episode. Oh, thank you. I have to say, I'm now, I was teasing you about writing your journal about it, but I mean, yeah.
我能把头发放下来了。你确实放下来了。我真的很兴奋。它有一点蓬松感。我其实觉得你这一集里的头发看起来很漂亮。哦，谢谢。我必须说，我现在，我刚才在取笑你写日记的事，但我的意思是，是的。
Well, it was- It was journal worthy. Thank you. It was the first episode that I didn't have my hair up in any way. No. So I wrote about it. Yeah, it's very nice.
嗯，它是——它是值得写进日记的。谢谢。这是我第一次没有以任何方式把头发扎起来的剧集。没有。所以我写下来了。是的，非常好。
So now at 12 minutes, 20 seconds, we meet Billy Merchant, who is played by Marcus York, as we discussed, and he is the property manager. Yes. And Jenna, he's here to just tell us information, right, about the parking lot. Yeah, tell us not to block the loading dock, even if we have our hazards on.
所以现在在12分20秒，我们见到了比利·默钱特，由马库斯·约克饰演，正如我们讨论过的，他是物业经理。是的，珍娜，他来这里只是为了告诉我们信息，对吧，关于停车场。是的，告诉我们不要挡住装卸区，即使我们开了危险警示灯。
He just wants to tell us some stuff about the building. Right, some of the building rules. And you said Michael sees this as an opportunity. Yes, because Billy is in a wheelchair, Michael has decided that he's pretty sure Billy is going to lecture us about the proper way to treat disabled people and back up the fact that Michael has been so wrong.
他只是想告诉我们一些关于大楼的事情。对，一些大楼规则。你说迈克尔把这看作是一个机会。是的，因为比利坐着轮椅，迈克尔决定他很确定比利会向我们讲授对待残疾人的正确方式，并支持迈克尔一直以来都错得离谱的事实。
Oh, Michael's been so wronged, right? So Marcus said that they really stuck to the script, him and Steve, for this scene. OK. up the fact that Michael has been so wrong. Oh, Michael's been so wronged, right? So Marcus said that they really stuck to the script, him and Steve for the scene, but then Steve threw an improv at him. I think I know what it is. Yes. So he said that Steve said, well, you know, we have a lot in common. And then he says, I'm going to stop you right there and leave.
哦，迈克尔一直被冤枉，对吧？所以马库斯说他们确实坚持了剧本，他和史蒂夫，为了这个场景。好的。支持迈克尔一直以来都错得离谱的事实。哦，迈克尔一直被冤枉，对吧？所以马库斯说他们确实坚持了剧本，他和史蒂夫为了这个场景，但后来史蒂夫对他进行了一次即兴表演。我想我知道那是什么。是的。所以他说史蒂夫说，嗯，你知道，我们有很多共同点。然后他说，我要在这里打断你，然后离开。
That's all scripted. Yeah. But then Steve improvised, who me? And Billy goes, no, me right now. He improvised that right back. And I was like, that was great, Marcus. That was so good. Marcus said that he wasn't ready for that improv. He wasn't sure. He said, when you guest star on a show, you don't know. Did they stick to the script? He had heard that we had a lot of improv background and things like that, but he said that Steve just kind of threw that and then he just reacted
那都是写好的剧本。是的。但后来史蒂夫即兴发挥说：“谁，我吗？”比利说：“不，就是我，现在。”他立刻即兴回了这一句。我当时就觉得，太棒了，马库斯。太精彩了。马库斯说他没准备好应对那种即兴表演。他不太确定。他说，当你作为客串明星参加节目时，你不知道他们是否会照着剧本演。他听说我们有很多即兴表演的背景之类的，但他没想到史蒂夫会突然来这么一下，而他只是做出了反应。
and that's like something he remembers as being really fun. Well, when Steve says that line, you know what, we aren't that different when I clamp my foot on the George Foreman grill, you see Mindy put her hand up to her mouth and then you see me full on laugh and turn to rain and rain smiles at me. Yeah, no, the front row.
那让他觉得非常有趣。嗯，当史蒂夫说那句台词时，你知道吗，当我们没那么不同时，当我把脚夹在乔治·福尔曼烤架上时，你看到明迪把手捂在嘴上，然后你看到我完全笑场了，转头看向雷恩，雷恩对我笑了。是的，不，前排。
The front row lost it. Row lost it. I have both of those. I'm like, Jenna, you completely break. Mindy, I expect to. I expect to see Mindy's hand cover her mouth, but you don't even hide it. I don't.
前排的人笑翻了。笑翻了。这两段我都有。我心想，珍娜，你完全破功了。明迪，我预料到了。我预料到会看到明迪用手捂住嘴，但你甚至都没掩饰。我没有。
You just turn and start laughing. Well, Brian is staring at the floor. Brian is Kevin. He floor. Brian is Kevin. He's having a hard time. He has got just like this laser focus onto the carpet which seems also unnatural and I think he's doing it not to laugh. He's also probably biting the inside of his mouth
你只是转过身开始笑。嗯，布莱恩盯着地板。布莱恩就是凯文。他盯着地板。布莱恩就是凯文。他很难受。他就像这样死死盯着地毯，这看起来也很不自然，我想他这么做是为了不笑出来。他可能还在咬自己的嘴唇内侧，
or inflicting some kind of pain on himself so he doesn't laugh. I wanted to point out that I think it's really sweet how the director chose to put Rain and I next to each other in that conference room scene. I would normally sit next to Jim, but I sat next to Dwight because Pam and Dwight are friends. Yes, they're friends now.
或者对自己施加某种痛苦，这样他就不会笑出来。我想指出的是，我觉得导演选择让雷恩和我坐在那场会议室戏的旁边，这真的很贴心。我通常会坐在吉姆旁边，但我坐在了德怀特旁边，因为帕姆和德怀特是朋友。是的，他们现在是朋友了。
Also in this scene, we learn that I guess Michael brushes his teeth for 10 seconds. 10 seconds. Wow. Okay. Yes. 10 seconds, wow, okay. So next we go to a scene with Michael and Ryan and Ryan is delivering him some pudding. Chocolate pudding. It's revealed that Ryan ground up some aspirin
同样在这一幕中，我们了解到迈克尔刷牙只刷10秒钟。10秒钟。哇。好吧。是的，10秒钟，哇，好吧。接下来我们进入迈克尔和瑞恩的场景，瑞恩正给他送布丁。巧克力布丁。原来瑞恩磨碎了一些阿司匹林，
and put it in the pudding. And so there's been this runner where Michael really, really wants some fresh yams and Ryan can't seem to find them anywhere. He asked them if he found them in Carbondale, which is where he found the pudding at a gas station in Carbondale. Fan question from Grellet, does a gas station in Carbondale always have fresh yams? I wanted to find out. I would think that no gas station had yams. I feel like Ryan isn't really trying that
放进了布丁里。所以一直有这样一个情节，迈克尔非常非常想吃新鲜的山药，而瑞恩似乎到处都找不到。他问他们是否在卡本代尔找到了，也就是他在卡本代尔的一个加油站找到布丁的地方。来自Grellet的粉丝提问，卡本代尔的加油站总是有新鲜山药吗？我想查清楚。我觉得没有加油站会有山药。我觉得瑞恩并没有真的那么
hard to look for these yams because I think if he just went to the grocery store. Carbondale is about 25 minutes outside of Scranton. Ryan hits a number of the sort of surrounding counties on his search for the yams. So I really looked hard and I could not find a gas station with yams in Carbondale and most of them didn't even look like they had Quick shops like maybe you could get gum, but some of them I felt like I couldn't even get a cup of coffee if you live in Carbondale Pennsylvania Let me know and if there's a gas station near you that sells yams. Will you tell us we'd love to know Jenna I have a question for you.
努力去寻找这些山药，因为我觉得如果他直接去杂货店的话。卡本代尔距离斯克兰顿大约25分钟车程。瑞恩在寻找山药的过程中去了周围的几个县。所以我真的很努力地找了，但在卡本代尔我找不到一家有山药的加油站，而且大多数加油站看起来甚至连便利店都没有，也许你能买到口香糖，但有些地方我觉得连杯咖啡都买不到。如果你住在宾夕法尼亚州的卡本代尔，请告诉我，如果你附近有卖山药的加油站，能告诉我们吗？我们很想知道。珍娜，我有个问题要问你。
What is it? How do I say this? Yeah. Oh, no. Did you ever think that you would stay up late looking for yams at gas stations in Carbondale? No. Also.
什么问题？怎么说呢？嗯。哦，不。你有没有想过你会熬夜在卡本代尔的加油站找山药？没有。还有。
You would Google map looking for yams and Carbondale? This is the kind of stuff we do for you guys. I'm allergic to yams and sweet potatoes by the way, so even if I had found them, I could never do anything for myself with this information. This was all for you. Next in this episode, Dwight collapses. He needs to go to the hospital and while we're walking to the elevator Dwight says it smells like chicken soup and Pam says I know that was
你会用谷歌地图找卡本代尔的山药吗？这就是我们为你们做的这类事情。顺便说一下，我对山药和红薯过敏，所以即使我找到了，我也无法用这些信息为自己做任何事。这一切都是为了你们。接下来在这一集中，德怀特晕倒了。他需要去医院，当我们走向电梯时，德怀特说闻起来像鸡汤，帕姆说我知道那是
improvised. The amount of scripted words that they had for us did not get us to the elevator so they told us just say some stuff and I loved shooting this scene with Rain. It was so much fun. It looked like it. It looked like you were having a good time. I really liked it. Also, I think he improvised that line where Jim says, what are you doing? And he says making Vietnam sounds or something like that as he's falling on the couch. Yes. But I did want to say something that was not improvised that's in the script is the water bottle that Jim picks up off of the plant and then is spraying him. That was in the scene.
即兴发挥的。他们给我们的剧本台词不足以支撑我们走到电梯，所以他们告诉我们随便说点什么。我很喜欢和雷恩拍这场戏。太有趣了。看起来确实如此。看起来你们玩得很开心。我真的很喜欢。另外，我想吉姆说“你在干什么？”的那句台词也是他即兴发挥的，他说他在倒在沙发上时发出了越南语的声音之类的。是的。但我确实想说一件不是即兴发挥、而是剧本里有的事，就是吉姆从植物上拿起水瓶喷他的那一幕。那是在剧本里的。
Well, I have a question. Yeah. At 15 minutes, 25 seconds. Yeah. Why? Why do they have to go in Meredith's van? So many fans wrote in about that. Why couldn't they go in Jim's car?
嗯，我有个问题。是的。在15分25秒。是的。为什么？他们为什么非要坐梅瑞狄斯的货车？很多粉丝写信问这个问题。为什么他们不能坐吉姆的车？
I get why Michael can't drive. I get that Dwight can't drive. But Jim, why didn't Jim say, that's fine, I don't want to ride in your gross van. I'll take my car. Here are his choices. Go in Meredith's van or put Dwight and Michael in his car. Dwight has already thrown up.
我明白为什么迈克尔不能开车。我明白德怀特不能开车。但吉姆，为什么吉姆不说，没关系，我不想坐你那辆恶心的货车。我开我的车。这是他的选择。坐梅瑞狄斯的货车，或者让德怀特和迈克尔坐他的车。德怀特已经吐了。
I mean, I don't know. Would you put them in your car? Yes, I would rather drive my car, an injured person in my car, where I know my car. Meredith's van is a hot mess. But because they took Meredith's van, they had that great funny scene of Dwight trying to drink the rum in the backseat.
我是说，我不知道。你会让他们坐你的车吗？是的，我宁愿开我的车，载一个受伤的人，因为我了解我的车。梅瑞狄斯的货车简直是一团糟。但因为他们坐了梅瑞狄斯的货车，他们才有了那场德怀特试图在后座喝朗姆酒的精彩搞笑戏份。
Oh my gosh. So John has said in interviews that that was one of the hardest times he's ever laughed on the show, was filming those Meredith Vance scenes. Well, I think these three guys, whenever they get in a car together, they lose it. Have you seen all the outtakes
天哪。所以约翰在采访中说过，那是他在节目中笑得最辛苦的一次，就是拍摄那些梅瑞狄斯货车的戏份。嗯，我觉得这三个人，只要他们聚在一起坐车，就会失控。你看过所有的花絮吗？
of them laughing their butts off, like in these cars? And also, I think that John, it wasn't Jim, that was John with that spray bottle. Oh, he had too much fun with that. We can't end this episode without me talking about one of my favorite things that Michael does is when he explains something that we all know, but he explains it to you as if he's the person
他们笑得前仰后合，就像在这些车里一样？而且，我觉得约翰，那不是吉姆，那是约翰拿着那个喷水瓶。哦，他玩得太开心了。我们不能在不谈论迈克尔最喜欢的行为之一的情况下结束这一集，那就是当他解释一些我们都知道的事情时，但他解释得好像他是
that invented it or he's the only one that knows it. Shotgun. Oh my gosh. So at 16 minutes, 38 seconds, he goes, "'The rules of shotgun are very simple and very clear. Whenever he does this stuff, I just live for it. I love it. I love it. In this episode, we learn Dwight's middle name.
发明它的人，或者他是唯一知道它的人。副驾驶。天哪。所以在16分38秒，他说：“副驾驶的规则非常简单且非常明确。”每当他做这些事时，我简直太喜欢了。我爱死这个了。我爱死这个了。在这一集中，我们知道了德怀特的中间名。
Is not Danger. It's Kurt. But fan question from Brianna, was Dwight saying his middle name Danger scripted or improvised? It was scripted. We also learn in this episode, you guys, that Creed as a teenager was in an iron lung.
不是“危险”（Danger）。是“库尔特”（Kurt）。但来自布里安娜的粉丝提问，德怀特说他的中间名是“危险”是剧本写的还是即兴发挥的？那是剧本写的。在这一集中，你们大家还了解到，克里德十几岁时曾待在铁肺里。
He says he was in an iron lung. Not that he had an iron lung, but he was, what? Like he's in an iron lung. That's what they are. That was the thing, you went inside. Yeah, you went inside of a thing called an iron lung, I guess. I don't know how it works.
他说他待在铁肺里。不是说他有一个铁肺，而是他，什么？就像他待在铁肺里。那就是它们的样子。那是那个东西，你钻进里面。是的，你钻进一个叫铁肺的东西里，我想。我不知道它是怎么运作的。
I don't either. I did not deep dive on iron lungs. I loved it though. I loved when Jim's like, how old are you? Or no, that was Michael, when Michael was like, how old are you? But anyway, we learned that Creed was in an iron lung as a teenager, which is hilarious. I love in this episode that Michael takes off his microphone. Yes. This is the first time we go radio silent, right?
我也不知道。我没有深入研究铁肺。但我很喜欢。我喜欢吉姆问“你多大了？”的时候，或者不，那是迈克尔，当迈克尔问“你多大了？”的时候。但总之，我们了解到克里德十几岁时待在铁肺里，这太搞笑了。我喜欢这一集中迈克尔摘下麦克风。是的。这是我们第一次进入“无线电静默”状态，对吧？
I think so. That we point out that we're actually mic'd. We sort of break that we're actually mic'd. We sort of break that fourth wall in that way. Yeah, I liked that. And then I love this scene, and this scene was not in the script. In our shooting draft of the script, they must have added this later.
我想是这样。我们指出我们实际上戴着麦克风。我们以那种方式打破了第四面墙。是的，我喜欢那样。然后我喜欢这一幕，这一幕不在剧本里。在我们拍摄的剧本草稿中，他们一定是后来加进去的。
I mean, probably while we were shooting, but this scene where Jim calls Pam and Angela pops her head over to over here if there's any news about Dwight and Pam clocks it. And then Pam goes over to Oscar and tells Oscar, Hey Oscar, I thought you'd like to know Dwight's going to be okay. And it zooms in on your face, and you're so relieved, and you can tell you're in love. I'm in love, I was worried about my man.
我是说，可能是在我们拍摄的时候，但这一幕是吉姆给帕姆打电话，安吉拉探出头来想听听有没有关于德怀特的消息，帕姆注意到了。然后帕姆走到奥斯卡身边告诉奥斯卡：“嘿，奥斯卡，我想你可能想知道德怀特会没事的。”镜头拉近你的脸，你如释重负，你能看出你恋爱了。我恋爱了，我担心我的男人。
One of the things I did, and we all did this in different ways as characters, if something interesting was happening at reception, even if it wasn't in my script that my character clocked it, I would just pop up and look over the partition. And the first time one of the camera guys caught me doing it, the writers loved this, and that kind of became a thing. So of course, if Pam is on the phone about Dwight, I'm going to pop my head over. But this one was scripted, that my head's there, that I'm listening in.
我做的一件事，我们所有人都以不同的方式作为角色这样做，如果前台发生了什么有趣的事情，即使我的剧本里没有写我的角色注意到了，我也会探出头来看看隔板。第一次摄像师拍到我这样做时，编剧们很喜欢，这后来就成了一个梗。所以当然，如果帕姆在电话里谈论德怀特，我肯定会探出头来。但这一幕是剧本写好的，我的头在那儿，我在偷听。
And I remember one of the things they told me is that they're gonna catch my head at the top. It's not a ton of time, Pam's gonna look back over and then I need to like disappear, right? Like I, and so we were playing around with this. So in one take, when you look back over, I just dropped to my knees. Do you notice how quickly?
我记得他们告诉我的事情之一是他们会拍到我的头顶。时间不多，帕姆会回头看，然后我需要消失，对吧？所以我们一直在尝试这个。所以在一次拍摄中，当你回头看时，我直接跪下了。你注意到有多快了吗？
You really do. And that's the one I think they kept in because I just like drop like a rock and they thought that was really funny. The very end of this, it's the final shot of Dwight in the CT scan machine and Michael tries to put his foot in. That was not in the script. That was an improvisation by Mr. Steve Carell. Of course, of course.
你真的跪下了。我想他们保留了那一条，因为我像块石头一样倒下，他们觉得那真的很有趣。这一集的最后，是德怀特在CT扫描机里的最后一个镜头，迈克尔试图把脚放进去。那不在剧本里。那是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔先生的即兴发挥。当然，当然。
So we learn in this episode that Dwight with a concussion is actually really a likable guy. Yeah. But he also steps out of his lane a little. With Pam, he becomes a friend. Jim didn't like that. And then he gets the jokes instead of Michael with the doctor.
所以我们在这一集中了解到，脑震荡的德怀特其实是一个非常讨人喜欢的人。是的。但他也有点越界了。他和帕姆成了朋友。吉姆不喜欢那样。然后他在医生那里抢了迈克尔的笑话。
And Michael didn't like that. And I don't know, I thought he was so adorable in this episode. Well, a lot of people pointed out that there are gonna be some future episodes that follow the Pam and Dwight friendship. And spoiler alert, in the end, Dwight calls Pam one of his best friends or his best friend.
迈克尔不喜欢那样。我不知道，我觉得他在这一集中太可爱了。嗯，很多人指出，未来会有一些剧集会延续帕姆和德怀特的友谊。剧透预警，最后，德怀特称帕姆为他最好的朋友之一，或者他最好的朋友。
I know. And it's really sweet. And I absolutely loved these. I love whenever Pam and Dwight have to team up. I think something about Pam that's true is that for as much as Dwight and or Michael annoy her, she really loves them. Like she does. They're her crazy cousin or zany uncle or whatever, but she loves them. She does love them. I have to think that Angela does not. If Angela doesn't like you she doesn't like you. She doesn't like you and I have to think that it was probably like a source of
我知道。这真的很贴心。我绝对喜欢这些。我喜欢帕姆和德怀特不得不联手的时候。我觉得帕姆身上有一点是真的，那就是尽管德怀特和/或迈克尔让她很烦，但她真的很爱他们。就像她做的那样。他们是她疯狂的表亲或古怪的叔叔什么的，但她爱他们。她确实爱他们。我不得不认为安吉拉不爱。如果安吉拉不喜欢你，她就是不喜欢你。她不喜欢你，我不得不认为这可能是一个
conflict for her and Dwight if Dwight was like well you know Pam was kind of I'm like oh Pam. You know I I'm gonna say I think the one person that Pam maybe didn't like was Angela. I know. Like I think she, you know, but she'll take that if you have nothing good to say, say nothing at all about Angela. Yeah, but I really don't think they liked each other. I don't think they did. Which is hilarious. If you have the DVDs and want to watch a really great deleted scene from this episode,
她和德怀特之间冲突的来源，如果德怀特说“嗯，你知道帕姆其实挺……”我会说“哦，帕姆”。你知道，我要说，我觉得帕姆可能唯一不喜欢的人就是安吉拉。我知道。就像我觉得她，你知道，但如果你没什么好话可说，她会接受“关于安吉拉什么也别说”。是的，但我真的不认为他们互相喜欢。我不认为他们喜欢。这太搞笑了。如果你有DVD，想看这一集中一个非常棒的删减片段，
my personal favorite is the scene where Jim and Michael, they are in the waiting room of the emergency room. Dwight is in the back, they're waiting in this lobby. I watched this. They are watching a telenovela. And it just made me laugh. They're just stuck in this hospital waiting room watching a telenovela and I loved it.
我个人最喜欢的是吉姆和迈克尔在急诊室候诊室的那一幕。德怀特在后面，他们在大厅里等着。我看过这个。他们在看一部肥皂剧。这让我笑了。他们只是被困在医院的候诊室里看肥皂剧，我太喜欢了。
Well guys, that's the injury. That's the injury. Angela did this podcast with an injury. That's how method she is. Do you think you subconsciously gave yourself an injury for the injury? No, no. Maybe? I think I can't.
好了，伙计们，这就是受伤。这就是受伤。安吉拉带着伤录了这个播客。她就是这么敬业。你觉得你是潜意识里为了受伤这个主题而让自己受伤了吗？不，不。也许？我想我不能。
Mind meld? I think I can't chew gum when I'm having a sassy rant. I was venting, popping gum. It's probably karma. I can't chew gum when I'm having a sassy rant. I was venting popping gum. It's probably karma. I don't know. I don't know. I think maybe you did it for the show. Well, listen.
心灵感应？我想我在发牢骚时不能嚼口香糖。我在发泄，嚼着口香糖。这可能是因果报应。我在发牢骚时不能嚼口香糖。我在发泄，嚼着口香糖。这可能是因果报应。我不知道。我不知道。我想也许你是为了节目才这么做的。好吧，听着。
Thank you. Thank you. You're excellent today. You're welcome. Guys, next week we'll be back with the secret where we very much do propel the Jim Pam storyline forward. Can Michael keep the secret that Jim told him on the Boos Cruise?
谢谢。谢谢。你今天表现很棒。不客气。伙计们，下周我们将带着《秘密》回归，我们确实推动了吉姆和帕姆的故事线。迈克尔能保守吉姆在游轮上告诉他的秘密吗？
The secret. The secret. Secret. My side of my tongue is numb. Secret. Angela's tongue will be better next week. It's a good thing. See you then.
秘密。秘密。秘密。我的舌头侧面麻了。秘密。安吉拉的舌头下周会好起来的。这是件好事。到时候见。
Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weis-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis.
再见。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。本集最初是与Earwulf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。
Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴西尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。